meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesministerin sehr
geehrte Frau Botschafterin ihre
Exzellenz schön dass Sie da sind ja
general major meine sehr verehrten Gäste
herzlich willkommen im Namen des
österreichischen
Verteidigungsministeriums zum zur
Präsentation des risikoberichtes
2023 des Risiko Bildes diese
Präsentation an sich wenn sie regelmäßig
hier sind wissen sie dass ist im
Regelfall sehr spannend in diesem Jahr
aber natürlich sehr sehr besonders wir
leben in wohl interessanteren Zeiten aus
vielen von uns lieb ist knapp ein Jahr
nach Beginn des Krieges in der Ukraine
werden sie heute hören wie Experten
Experten des Österreich deutschen
Bundesheeres die riskern in diesem Jahr
einschätzen sie werden aber weit über
das militärische hinausgehen wenn uns
auch geopolitische Risken ansehen die
Auswirkungen dass er noch laufenden
Krieges die Risiken die es womöglich
gibt für die zivile Infrastruktur und in
einer hochkarätigen Experten und
Expertenrunde werden wir dann nach der
Präsentation dieses Risiko Bildes und
ganz konkret ansehen was diese riskern
für Österreich für Europa für uns alle
bedeuten ich darf mir noch kurz
vorstellen ich bin nicht Corinna Milborn
ich darf sie sollte sich das jemand
gefragt haben
ist meine Chefin mein Name ist Werner
Segger bin einer der Nachrichten
Moderatorinnen Moderatoren bei Puls 24
und freue mich dass ich heute da sein
darf dann beginnen wir
schauen wir uns einen Film einen kurzen
Film auf eine mögliche Zukunft an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im Jahr 2035 haben sich die globalen
machtpolitischen Entwicklungen wie folgt
gebildet die Verhältnisse zwischen den
Großmächten und deren Regionalverbänden
sind zurückrüttet und von Misstrauen
geprägt das Wettrennen um die dominante
Weltmacht zwischen den USA und China hat
sich weiter verschärft die Chinesen sind
aber zunehmend bereit zur Durchsetzung
ihrer ordnungspolitischen Vorstellungen
militärische Mittel einzusetzen
[Musik]
der Westen wird in erster Linie mit
wirtschaftlichen Druck Cyberattacken und
gezielter des Information zu
destabilisieren versucht die
Vormachtstellung der USA ist
technologisch und militärisch noch
erhalten die Hauptinteressen haben sich
nach dem Motto America first in den
westpazifischen Raum verlagert das
politische System Russlands ist relativ
stabil Macht und Kontrolle darüber gehen
aber zunehmend verloren von Westen hat
man sich weitgehend abgeschottet gegen
die eigene Bevölkerung mit repressiv
vorgegangen
punktuelle Verflechtungen mit Europa
gibt es noch im Energiebereich russland
fordert Europa aber ständig heraus mit
Cyberattacken Verknappung von Energie
und gezielter Desinformation an den
Ostgrenzen Europas auch militärisch
diverse Wirtschaftskrisen haben zu
ungleichen wirtschaftsentwicklungen und
zu deutlichen wohlstandsunterschieden
geführt Rohstoffe sind erheblich teurer
geworden
wirtschaftskonflikte befeuern die
konfrontative Prägung des
internationalen Systems zwischen den
Großmächten mit hochgerüsteten Armeen
kommt es vom März zu Konflikten und der
Anwendung hybrider Mittel und in Form
von Stellvertreter kriegen die Gefahr
von Einsatz von Massenvernichtungswaffen
steigt allerdings insbesondere im
westpazifischen Raum kontinuierlich an
der Klimawandel verursacht vermehrt
Dürre und Wasserknappheit Rohstoff und
Lebensmittelmangel sind die Folge
[Musik]
die politische Integration in der EU ist
nicht erreicht worden eine Gruppe von
Kernstaaten hat sich zu einer vertieften
Zusammenarbeit in unterschiedlichen
Politikfeldern zusammengeschlossen die
gemeinsame sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik beschränkt sich auf
die Sicherung der EU-Außengrenze
abgestützt durch die NATO die immer
präsente militärische Bedrohung
Russlands ist zur sicherheitspolitischen
Priorität geworden
in Österreich spitzt sich das
sicherheitspolitische Umfeld zu es gibt
kaum erkennbare Entwicklungen die eine
Eliminierung von diversen risikobildern
zulassen im Unterschied zu früheren
Risikoanalysen ist die aktuelle
Einschätzung durch umfangreiche
selbstverstärkende Effekte multiple
Krisen beeinflusst wie die
covid-pandemie die Energiekrise oder die
überdurchschnittliche Inflation
gesamtverschärfen sich militärische
Risiken unter anderem durch Hybride
Bedrohungen signifikant der mögliche
Angriff auf einen EU-Mitgliedstaat
Raketen und Drohnenangriffe aller Art
eine Verschärfung der Konflikte im
südlichen und östlichen krisenbogen und
systemischer Terrorismus
die Analysen des Bundesministeriums für
Landesverteidigung zeigen ganz klar dass
das Umfeld Europas und Österreichs
unsicherer komplexer und gefährlicher
wird aus diesem Grund wird sowohl
Österreich als auch die EU deutlich mehr
für seine Sicherheit investieren müssen
als die letzten 15 Jahre
[Musik]
wir Menschen haben ja eine
Herausforderung wir sind oft auf die
unmittelbare Erfahrung angewiesen das
ist dann dieser Moment wenn ich eben auf
die Herdplatte greife aber das führt
dann oft zu überstürzten Reaktionen umso
wichtiger ist sich ein Bild der Zukunft
zu machen sich zu überlegen wie kann die
aussehen welche Risken stehen hier vor
uns wie kann ich ihnen dann auch
begegnen das wollen wir heute gemeinsam
tun zu Begrüßung bitte ich den Hausherrn
zu uns auf die Bühne den Generalanwalt
des österreichischen Raiffeisenverbandes
und genau der Militär Erwin hammeseder
bitte schön
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesministerin sehr
geehrte Frau Volksanwältin Exzellenzen
sehr geehrte
politische Vertreter
auf Ebene der
sicherheitssprecher und wer Sprecher ich
freue mich sehr meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren dass sie heute wieder
so zahlreiche in unser Haus gekommen
sind zu einer einzigartigen
Veranstaltung die es in Österreich gibt
und ich freue mich daher auch sehr dass
heute viele Vertreter aus der Wirtschaft
da sind weil gerade für uns aus der
Wirtschaft da ist diese Veranstaltung
unglaublich wichtig risikobild 2023
der Direktion für
Verteidigungspolitik und internationale
Beziehungen diese Veranstaltung hat im
vorm April erst stattgefunden und damals
stand mir unmittelbar
im Eindruck oder unter dem Eindruck des
24.2 des Kriegsbeginns in der Ukraine
das risikobild 2023 ist eine ganz
wesentliche Grundlage für uns aus der
Wirtschaft für neue Beurteilungen und
Analysen der riesigen die wir auch
anzustellen haben
wir bekommen auch Schlussfolgerungen
geliefert für allfällige Änderungen des
Business-Modells und auch strategische
Ausrichtungen
mögliche Prävention zum gegenmaßnahmen
sind sehr sehr wichtig dass die aktiv
entwickelt wird weil die dann auf die
Resilienz der Wirtschaft einzahlen und
natürlich auch der Republik Österreich
der 24.2 hat tiefe unwiderrufliche
Kerben in die Geschichtsschreibung
geschlagen es wurde das Völkerrecht
gebrochen die europäische Sicherheit und
Friedensordnung wurde schwerst
erschüttert neue und höchst komplexe
Bedrohungsszenarien man hat hier auch in
den Film angesprochen gesehen sind
entstanden und was natürlich auch ganz
schwer wiegt auch für uns in der
Wirtschaft die wir in diesem Land
Ukraine auch tätig sind
humanikarte Strophe die es wohl in
dieser Zeit niemand geglaubt hat dass es
noch einmal geben könnte der Krieg
trifft alle uns alle trifft die gesamte
Bevölkerung und heute im raiffeisenhaus
möchte ich als Repräsentant auch der
Wirtschaft einen kurzen Blick auf die
dramatischen
ökonomischen Verwerfungen stellen
insbesondere was auch die Sanktionen
bedeuten die aber darüber lasse ich
keine Zweifel absolut notwendig sind die
weltweiten Risiken verschärfen sich
das ist auch eine unmissverständliche
Kernaussage des diesjährigen global
Report denn das World Economic Forum
kürzlich präsentiert hat
und die größten wirtschaftlichen Risiken
die auch für Österreich dort
angesprochen sind sind Inflation aus
ihren vielfältigen Gründen heraus und
damit verbunden die diversesten
preisschocks und weitere Bedrohungen
sind ganz klar ein möglicher
Zusammenbruch von Infrastruktur im Falle
eines Blackouts aber auch die Folgen des
drei zum globale Ressourcen die für uns
in der Wirtschaft unverzichtbar sind und
auch Auswirkungen von extremen
Wetterereignissen und der Krieg in der
Ukraine hat die internationalen
Lieferketten die sind das Rückgrat das
internationalen Handels massiv unter
Druck gesetzt und mitunter auch
zusammenbrechen lassen
diese
wohlterabilität ist ein Beispiel was es
heißt abhängig zu sein abhängig zu sein
von
verschiedenen Regimen und unsere
globalisierte Welt ist einem
ordentlichen Maß an Unsicherheit
konfrontiert
Globalisierung bedeutet Spezialisierung
in der Regel in der Wirtschaft zum
Beispiel bei der Produktion von Gütern
die immer wieder woanders hinaus
gelagert wurden und führt insbesondere
dann in Krisenzeiten im Krisenfall zu
sehr ungesunden Abhängigkeiten im
Kontext der globalen Bedrohungen steht
natürlich auch der Krisen der
Klimawandel kurz zusammengefasst meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren die
globalisierte Welt und der Welthandel
sind sehr verletzlich geworden
Risiken und Abhängigkeiten müssen daher
völlig neu
bewertet und beurteilt werden und es
geht um Resilienz es geht um Prävention
um eine höhere Resilienz dann zu
erreichen und es geht aus dem
Blickwinkel der Wirtschaft um die
Fokussierung auf allfällig eine
verstärkte Regionalisierung als eine der
möglichen Antworten
es ist wohl ein Gebot der Stunde
dass wir uns von diesen Abhängigkeit
Stück für Stück weit entfernen und
Wertschöpfung wieder verstärkt in die EU
hinein verlagern und natürlich damit
auch auf unsere nationale Ebene sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren einige Worte
lassen Sie mich auch als Miliz
Beauftragter der Frau Bundesministerin
sagen der russische Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine hat sehr deutlich gemacht
dass eine gut aufgestellte
Landesverteidigung von existenzieller
Bedeutung ist und das zeigt sich auch in
den diversesten Umfragen wie die
Bevölkerung das sieht beim
Vertrauensindex und kein Weg führt daran
vorbei dass wir ein modernes Bundesheer
haben und brauchen das sehen wir aus der
Wirtschaft so dass auch in der Lage ist
diese komplexen Risiken und Bedrohungen
adäquat zu begegnen und auch abarbeiten
zu können im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
das Bundesheer hat da die Schlüsselrolle
für die Republik wenn es um den Schutz
des Landes und damit auch der
Bevölkerung geht ich begrüße der
ausdrücklich
den neuen Budgetpfad den die
österreichische Bundesregierung
beschlossen hat es ist eine deutliche
Erhöhung die höchste Erhöhung und diese
deutliche Erhöhungen finanziellen
Mitteln bringt auf Basis des
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetzes
auch eine mittelfristige Absicherung des
budget-pfades und auch das wird sehr
positive Auswirkungen in der
österreichischen Wirtschaft haben das
höchste Budget in der Geschichte da darf
man stolz sein wenn so ein Rekorder mehr
Rechte ist Frau bundesministerinnen und
das ist nur erreicht worden weil du Frau
Bundesministerin Dichter unglaublich
eingesetzt hast in der österreichischen
des Regierung und das ist ein Erfolg wo
wir dir ein herzliches Dankeschön sagen
das ist einzigartig
[Applaus]
es beginnt damit eine Phase von
Investitionen und auch das nachrüstens
und ich sage nicht nur das als
milizoffice und milizbeauftragter
sondern auch als Repräsentant in der
Wirtschaft der heute hier Gelegenheit
hat auch zu Ihnen zu sprechen
rücken wir wieder die umfassende
Landesverteidigung und damit auch die
wirtschaftliche Landesverteidigung als
Fundament für die Stärkung der Resilienz
unserer Republik in den Mittelpunkt
einer Vielzahl von Maßnahmen und
Handlungen in diesem Sinne wünsche ich
Ihnen heute einen sehr interessanten
Vormittag ich bin sicher
es ist aufbereitet der Tisch ist
angerichtet und ich wünsche Ihnen auch
entsprechend wichtige Rückschlüsse diese
dann insbesondere in der Wirtschaft in
den vorstandsständen und in den
Geschäftsführungen
diskutieren alles Gute viel Tatkraft
Durchhaltevermögen und Erfolg für die
Zukunft vielen Dank
[Applaus]
vielen herzlichen Dank an die genauen
Wald des österreichischen
Raiffeisenverbandes
Dankeschön interessant natürlich wie sie
gesagt haben die gut aufgestellte
Landesverteidigung das verstehen wir
spätestens seit einem Jahr jetzt wieder
etwas sehr sehr wichtiges interessantes
auch dass sie nachrüsten gesagt haben
nicht aufrüsten aber für all das eben
für die gut aufgestellte
Landesverteidigung ist Frau
Bundesministerin klar der Tanner
zuständig sie haben schon applikiert
einmal geht's noch und ich bitte sie um
ihre Kinder bitteschön
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Generalanwalt
generalmeseder sehr geehrter Herr
Generalsekretär sektionchef dr kamisch
stellvertretend für alle
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter meines
Hauses
Exzellenzen schön dass Sie da sind
Vertreter der politischen Parteien
Abgeordnete wersprecher Gäste aus der
Wirtschaft sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
in Wahrheit hatte daher Generalanwalt
schon sehr vieles gesagt die Inhalte
meiner Rede durchaus auch vorweggenommen
die wichtigsten Punkte auch angesprochen
jetzt frage ich mich trage ich denn noch
dieses vor
ich glaube es gibt nur einige Punkte die
zu ergänzen sind und ich beginne da
vielleicht beim Titel unseres heurigen
risikobildes das ganz bewusst Krieg um
Europa genannt worden ist das ist kein
Zufall dieser Titel der wurde bewusst
gewählt weil er in kurzen Worten
ausdrückt warum es dieses Mal in der
Jahresvorschau geht
Krieg um Europa das heißt grundsätzlich
drei Dinge
erstens den Krieg in Europa durch den
Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine
zweitens den Krieg gegen westliche Werte
und drittens den Krieg gegen die
europäische Wirtschaft ich möchte an
dieser Stelle dir Herr Generalanwalt
ganz herzlich danken dass der
einladungskreis noch einmal erweitert
worden ist und so viele Vertreter der
Wirtschaft heute auch da sind schön dass
Sie da sind und danke dir für diese
Weitsicht
wir sehen dass unglaublich viele
Folgewirkungen und Risiken verknüpfter
sind die dann auch noch durch eines
nämlich den globalen Klimawandel und
weitere Faktoren verstärkt werden das
hat nicht zuletzt auch der Film zu
Beginn sehr deutlich gezeigt ja und
deshalb ist der in meinem Ressort
angesiedelte
risikobildprozess für Österreich im
europäischen Umfeld auch so breit
aufgestellt die Jahresvorschau mit dem
Risiko Bild entsteht durch einen
fundierten und einen bewährten Prozess
die Publikation gibt einen Überblick
über die für Österreich und Europa
sicherheitsrelevanten Entwicklungen
Risiken Konflikte ja und es wird
natürlich auch versucht mögliche
Antworten zu geben Antworten auf die
Sicherheit und verteidigungspolitischen
Herausforderungen 2023 unsere Leute im
Verteidigungsministerium sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die arbeiten hier mit
nationalen und mit international
Expertinnen und Experten zusammen sowohl
aus dem militärischen als auch aus dem
zivilen Bereich ja und darüber hinaus
und da liegt das Risiko Bild einer
ständigen Evaluierung und Prüfung das
war nicht zuletzt notwendig nach dem 24
Februar 2022 wo so vieles neu beurteilt
werden musste weil der Angriff
auf die Ukraine Auswirkungen in fast
alle Regionen der Welt hat und in so
viele
Lebensbereiche auch hineinwirkt ja kurz
gesagt
das Verteidigungsministerium beurteilt
die Auswertung des ukraine-krieges als
die größte Bedrohung Österreichs und
Europas mit dieser Bedrohung hängt
unglaublich vieles zusammen eine Zunahme
der Migration die weitere Konfrontation
Russlands mit der Europäischen Union
eine Verschärfung der Energiekrise die
Störung der Lieferketten eine
starkflation und insgesamt eine nicht
absehbare Eskalation des Krieges
die Hybriden Angriffe Russlands auf
europäische Staaten haben einen weiteren
Aspekt gezeigt den auch du schon
angesprochen hast Herr generalm wir
sehen wir haben gesehen wie verletzlich
Strukturen und Systeme sind die wir als
Gesellschaft eigentlich zuvor also
stabil angesehen und der achtet haben ja
und wir sehen noch etwas eine Krise die
steht meistens nicht allein da in den
vergangenen Jahren haben sich
verschiedene Krisenlagen immer wieder
auch gehäuft und sich gegenseitig auch
aufgeschaukelt da Leiter der Gruppe
Direktion Verteidigungspolitik prägetier
dr Peter vorhofer wird in seinem
heutigen Vortrag über das Risiko in
Österreich 2023 mit einigen Beispielen
auch noch näher eingehen
was können die Antworten sein was ist
die sicherheitspolitische Antwort auf
eine so komplexe Lage
sehr viele von ihnen werden das hier an
dieser Stelle bei dieser Veranstaltung
oder auch bei vielen anderen schon
gehört haben betone ist immer wieder ich
bin überzeugt davon dass der Schlüssel
in der Zusammenarbeit liegt die
Zusammenarbeit auf gesamtstaatlicher und
europäischer Ebene die Zusammenarbeit
über zivile und militärische Grenzen
hinweg
über die Notwendigkeit der
verteidigungspolitischen Kooperationen
über gemeinsames Strategie Dokumente wie
den strategischen Kompass und andere
Mittel wird dann Generalsekretär dr
Arnold kammerling seinem Vortrag er auch
noch näher eingehen und insbesondere
auch zu den verteidigungspolitischen
Ableitungen für Österreich nach der
folgenden Panel Diskussion
es ist interessant vor fünf Jahren hat
das Verteidigungsministerium in seiner
damaligen
Risikoanalyse 25
Bedrohungen erkannt ich weiß nicht wir
sind deine Zeiten war sind ja zwei
meiner Vorgänger heute auch hier da war
es glaube ich noch weniger für heuer
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren sind es 73
Bedrohungen der analysiert worden sind
die Welt ist ohne Zweifel in den
vergangenen paar Jahren noch instabiler
geworden und
vollkommen richtig es führt nichts daran
vorbei dass das österreichische
Bundesheer dass wir nachrüsten dass das
Bundesheer dementsprechend auch gestärkt
wird das macht der Krieg in und um
Europa sehr deutlich dass eine gut
aufgestellte Landesverteidigung nicht
zuletzt für eine militärische neutralen
Stadt wie Österreich von existenzieller
Bedeutung ist
eine weitere Erkenntnis können wir auch
noch ziehen neben Hybriden Bedrohungen
hat nun auch wieder die konventionelle
Kriegsführung an Bedeutung gewonnen wir
müssen uns daher auch auf dem
militärischen Schutz der
österreichischen Souveränität gegen
konventionell agierende Kräfte
zurückbesinnen das erfordert einen
Ausbau und eine Festigung der
militärischen Fähigkeiten wenn man
allein an unsere Panzer denkt das letzte
milchpaket war unter einem meiner
Vorgänger unter Minister faslamt das
heißt wir haben unglaublich viel zu tun
wir haben unglaublich viel zu tun um
unser österreichisches Bundesheer zu
einem modernen her aufzustellen
nachzurüsten dass wir all diesen
Szenarien und Bedrohungen auch effektiv
begegnen können und dass wir unsere
Aufgaben zum Schutz und zur Sicherheit
der Bevölkerung auch erfüllen können
ja und das erfüllt mich tatsächlich mit
der Stolz aber auch mit Dankbarkeit dass
es gemeinsam gelungen ist über alle
parteipolitischen Grenzen hinweg das
höchste landesverteidigungsbudget der
Geschichte zu erreichen und 16
Milliarden Euro für die kommenden Jahre
machen es uns möglich dass wir viele
Investitionen tätigen können die
jahrelang auf der Strecke geblieben sind
wir tun das unter dem motto-mission
vorwärts wir wissen genau was wir
beschaffen müssen einer meiner Vorgänge
ich sehen gerade nicht daher
generalmaier mein direkter Vorgänger
Herr generalmaier Stallinger der im
übrigen heute einen runden Geburtstag
feiert herzliche Gratulation an dieser
Stelle noch einmal
[Applaus]
ja du hast uns die Grundlagen geliefert
mit deinem Bericht wir wissen was wir zu
beschaffen haben Ausrüstung Waffen und
Gerät wir wissen auch dass wir uns um
unser Personal kümmern müssen dass wir
auch da entsprechend attraktive
Maßnahmen ergreifen müssen und für den
zehnjährigen Aufbauplan der erstellt
worden ist gilt es an dieser Stelle auch
unserem generalmangister Günther hofbau
ein ganz großes Dankeschön zu sagen er
wird diesen später auch noch erläutern
danke für deine so wichtige Arbeiter
generalmaier
[Applaus]
nachdem die Erläuterungen im Detail dann
durch generalmaier Hofbauer erfolgen
wird mache ich es nur kurz die
investitionsschwerpunkte sind relativ
gleich ob es irgendwann einmal im
Parlament gesagt in Wahrheit müssen wir
an jedem Eck und Ende investieren wir
tun das aber auch sehr
zielgerichtet dass er sei an dieser
Stelle auch gesagt weil sie Frau
Volksanwältin gerade an weil es auch
darum geht und weil wir uns schon
bewusst sein müssen dass all das was wir
investieren Steuergeld ist wir werden
keinen Euro investieren verschwenden wir
werden das alles auch transparent tun
die investitionsschwerpunkte die wir
gesetzt haben sind ganz klar das beginnt
bei der Mobilität der Einsatzkräfte geht
über den Schutz der Soldatinnen und
Soldaten mit der Beschaffung von
moderner Ausrüstung Waffen und Gerät
bezahlter KI äh der Kasernen zur
Stärkung der
Verteidigungsbereitschaft
Kasernen die dann auch tatsächlich
autark sind die einen hohen Schutz Grad
ausweisen mit ausreichenden ver
stärkungsgütern auch versehen sind und
auch die selbstständige Erzeugung von
Energie möglich machen und eine weitere
Folge dann auch sollen diese zu vollen
sicherheitsinseln werden die dann im
Einsatzfall zu Unterstützung und zur
Versorgung von regionalen
Blaulichtorganisationen wie Polizei
Rettung oder Feuerwehr dienen sollen das
heißt auch unseren Baudirektor wird
nicht Fahrt im rüstungschef wird nicht
Fahrt es gibt unglaublich vieles zu tun
in unserem Haus aber all dieses zu tun
ohne sich um eines der wesentlichen
Dinge zu kümmern wäre auch verkehrt und
ich bin dankbar dass du das angesprochen
hast wir müssen zusätzlich die
umfassende Landesverteidigung in
Österreich ich formuliere so
wiederbeleben
worum geht es dabei es geht neben der
militärischen Landesverteidigung auch um
die zivile Landesverteidigung die
geistige Landesverteidigung die
wirtschaftliche Landesverteidigung und
wir haben dies ergänzt durch die
ökologische Landesverteidigung mit der
militärischen Landesverteidigung da geht
es um den Schutz der Neutralität um die
Verteidigung der Souveränität mit
militärischen Mitteln zivilen
Landesverteidigung Funktionsfähigkeit
staatlicher Einrichtungen zu
gewährleisten ja die wirtschaftliche
Landesverteidigung in Erhalt der
Leistungsfähigkeit der Vermeidung von
Störungen der Wirtschaft die
Stabilisierung des Arbeitsmarktes die
Versorgung der Bevölkerung mit
lebensnotwendigen Gütern ja und bei der
ökologischen Landesverteidigung da ist
die Nachhaltigkeit und der Umgang mit
Ressourcen das große Thema eines soll
der wichtigsten Dinge
die geistige Landesverteidigung
die Bereitschaft die geistige
Bereitschaft zur Unterstützung des
Bundesheeres in der Bewältigung seiner
Aufgaben aber sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren es geht da auch um die
Bereitschaft jedes und jeder einzelnen
die wir fördern müssen jedes und jeder
einzelnen Beitrag zur Sicherung der
staatlich gesellschaftlichen
Lebensgrundlagen zu leisten und da bin
ich wirklich sehr froh dass es uns
gelungen ist dass in den neuen
Lehrplänen für die Bildungseinrichtungen
mit meinem Ministerkollegen Martin
polasche eine Adaption gelungen ist dass
wir die nächste Generation noch
entsprechend darauf vorbereiten die
umfassende Landesverteidigung ist
essentiell für die Sicherheit und für
die Krisen Festigkeit unseres Landes
und wenn der eine oder andere glaubt
dass das am Kasernen Zaun endet dann ist
das glaube ich nicht der richtige Ansatz
sondern dort beginnt sie erst sie muss
in Schulen in Unternehmen in Familien
stattfinden um ein Bewusstsein auch zu
schaffen
denn eines glaube ich spüren wir alle
unser Leben wird wohl nie wieder so sein
wie es war aber und das ist auch klar
wir wissen um diesen Umstand und wir
können und wir werden etwas dagegen tun
und damit wir auch wissen was auf uns
zukommt dafür brauchen wir eben diese
jahresforscher mit dem risiko-bild auf
wissenschaftlicher Grundlage ich freue
mich auch dass der Leiter unserer
wissenschaftlichen Kommission heute da
ist sich danke allen Verantwortlichen
allen die an der Entstehung dieser so
wichtigen Publikation mitgewirkt haben
ich bin überzeugt davon dass der heute
präsentierte Band einen wichtigen
Beitrag zum Verständnis und so
Weiterentwicklung der
sicherheitspolitischen Bewusstseins in
Österreich leisten wird ich freue mich
auf die penner-diskussion ich wünsche
Ihnen uns allen mit den heutigen
Beiträgen der Expertinnen und Experten
ein erkenntnisreichen und einen
spannenden Vormittag ich danke Ihnen
[Applaus]
vielen Dank an Frau Bundesministerin
Claudia Tannert aber sehr sehr viel
drinnen das ist schon mal ein bisschen
auch angesprochen haben vielleicht
erlaube ich mir mehr herauszunehmen
diese drei zentralen Themen einmal der
Krieg in der Ukraine haben sie gesagt
Frau Ministerin dann auch der Krieg
gegen oder um die westlichen Wert und zu
guter Letzt auch ein Krieg gegen die
europäische Wirtschaft werden wir jetzt
konkreter schauen wir in das risikobild
2023 sie sind vorhin schon angesprochen
worden bitte den Leiter der Direktion
für Verteidigungspolitik auf die Bühne
dr vegetier Peter vorhofer bitte schön
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesminister sehr
geehrter Herr kleiner hammerseder meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren seit
mehreren Jahren präsentiert das
Verteidigungsministerium diese
Risikoeinschätzung und das dient nicht
nur uns selbst um die
Verteidigungspolitik weiterzuentwickeln
beziehungsweise dem militärischen
Beurteilungen näher zu treten und diese
zu unterstützen hier besonders möchte ja
wenn man mit den hammerhofbauer wo wir
sehr eng miteinander zusammenarbeiten
aber es gibt noch einen
gesamtstaatlichen Ansatz für diese
Veranstaltung und diese Präsentation und
das ist der eine Information an die
gesamte österreichische Bevölkerung
welche Risiken und ins Haus stehen und
in zweiter Weise und das ist bereits
auch angesprochen worden ist es
entsprechenden Entscheidungsträgern
Möglichkeiten für Ableitungen dazu zu
geben und diese Konsequenz diese
Konsequenz Analyse ist ganz enorm
wichtig und bildet den zweiten Schritt
eigentlich unserer Arbeit darüber wird
dann noch unser kanalsekretär Dr kamiton
in weiterer Folge noch sprechen wir
haben in den letzten Jahren würde ich
sagen die Begriffe Krise und Katastrophe
unverhältnismäßig oft gehört ich kann
leider nicht sagen dass ich dieses Bild
ändern kann alle Megatrends die wir
analysieren weisen auf eine
Verschlechterung hin und es ist
natürlich immer schwer auch emotional am
Anfang eines Jahres wo man versucht
sozusagen mit neuen Mut und neuer
Hoffnung das Jahr zu beginnen diese
Nachrichten zu bekommen
in dieser negativen Konstellation muss
man aber schon auch sagen und die Frau
Bundesminister hat es schon angedeutet
die Tatsache alleine dass wir wissen was
auf uns zukommt ist schon ein positiver
Aspekt und wir können auf das eingehen
und auf das reagieren
wir analysieren zwischen 70 und 80
Risiken pro Jahr und es ist natürlich
nicht möglich hier alle im Detail
darzustellen deshalb werde ich in fünf
Gruppen das machen und zwei besonders
hervorheben meine Damen und Herren bevor
ich aber da einsteige möchte ich aus
meiner langjährigen verteidigungs- und
sicherheitspolitischen Erfahrung schon
noch vier Punkte vier Botschaften
vielleicht an Sie weitergeben die mir
besonders wichtig sind das eine ist und
es ist heute schon leicht angesprochen
worden das ist der Faktor der
Globalisierung die Globalisierung wird
zunehmen und ist zunehmend ein massiver
sicherheitsrisikofaktor und wenn wir das
nicht begreifen und sozusagen darauf
reagieren werden wir in dieser
Abhängigkeit weiter massive
Sicherheitsrisiken empfangen
das zweite ist die technische
Entwicklung es ist so dass wir heute als
Menschen entweder versetzt oder
gezwungen werden
konfliktakteur oder konfliktbetroffener
zu sein das heißt es bedeutet jedes
Individuum trägt eine globale Dimension
in sich das hat in der Mensa
Menschheitsgeschichte noch nie gegeben
der vier dritte Punkt den ich ansprechen
möchte ist die Zivilgesellschaften und
hier möchte ich schon die europäischen
Zivilgesellschaften hervorheben haben
noch nicht realisiert dass sie wieder
Teil eines Krieges und Konfliktes sind
ohne dass sie dabei eine Uniform anhaben
auch meiner Meinung nach ein ganz
wichtiger Bereich den wir uns immer
wieder in Erinnerung rufen sollten und
der vierte Bereich die vierte Botschaft
die ich Ihnen mitgeben möchte ist dass
wir wenn wir
die zukünftigen Krisen bewältigen wollen
nur eindimensional denken oder in
bestimmten Kategorien ich greife heraus
vielleicht eine geografische Kategorie
haben wir bereits eine strategische
Fehleinschätzung gemacht die
Multidimensionalität muss ich auch in
unseren Analysen und in unserem Denken
niederschlagen meine Damen und Herren
zusammengefasst möchte ich jetzt fünf
große Gruppen ansprechen das erste ist
es wurde schon ein bisschen angedeutet
diese
multi-multiplen Risiken wenn wir so
umschreiben wollen und wir haben das
voriges Jahr hier bei dieser
Veranstaltung bereits angekündigt und
sie sind eingetreten und greife nur zwei
Beispiele heraus wenn sie sehen unser
Gesundheitssystem durch die Pandemie
enorm sozusagen unter Druck gesetzt die
Rezension die daraus entstanden ist
global hat zu Überschuldung der Staaten
geführt ein Strang der zweite Strang der
durch den Ukraine kriegt ausgelöst wurde
und uns eine Inflation engagiert hat die
wir seit 1970 nicht mehr gesehen haben
hat auch weiter zu dazu beigetragen dass
die Nationalstaaten in eine
Überschuldung gehen weil sie
abfederungsmaßnahmen durchführen wollen
und das führt jetzt in Kombination mit
vielen vielen vielen anderen Faktoren
dazu dass wir das von uns gewohnt des
Sozialstaatsmodell gefährden das
bedeutet in weiterer Folge dass wir das
was wir aus sozialen Frieden bezeichnen
in unserer Gesellschaft massiv gefährdet
sind
als nächstes die neue konfrontative
geopolitische Lage meine Damen und
Herren im Film ist es bereits
dargestellt worden die Systemkonkurrenz
zwischen der USA und China wird uns
massiv begleiten in den nächsten Jahren
und parallel dazu haben wir eine
erodierende regelbasierende Weltordnung
durch den Ukraine Krieg wir haben
weiters eine
Ungleichheit der Staaten stärker
hervorgebracht und sie sind immer
stärker in in das Bewusstsein getreten
in Kombination mit den großen
wohlstandsunterschieden dies alles mit
vielen Faktoren führt natürlich dazu
dass das international System massiv
destabilisiert und konfrontative wird
als drittes haben wir eine regionale
verstärkte Konzentration und Konflikte
zu erwarten weil in den krisenräumen die
uns so bekannt sind nahosten
Afrika und ähnliches Meer dort
kulminieren getrenntfaktoren und zwar in
ein negativen Sinne das bedeutet
geringes Wirtschaftswachstum hohe
bevölkerungswachung geringe
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit starke
Auswirkungen des Klimawandels und ein
geringer digitalisieren das alles trägt
dazu bei dass wir das spüren werden der
vierte Bereich wir nennen es so die
Resilienz gefährdeten extreme Ereignisse
wir wissen noch nicht ob die Pandemie
besiegt ist wir wissen noch nicht ob es
nicht neue Virusvarianten gibt
gepaart mit dem Umstand dass die
Auswirkungen des Klimawandels und zwar
die großen Auswirkungen erst in den
nächsten Jahren eintreten werden und
zugleich haben wir einen parallel
parallel ablaufenden Prozess den wir als
dekarbonisierungseffekt bezeichnen der
in der Welt komplett neuer geopolitische
Situationen und der mit Konfliktlinien
hervorrufen wird also auch hier eine
Verschärfung in diesem Sinne und
schließlich und endlich haben wir einen
Anstieg der sicherheitspolitischen
Bedeutung von ökonomischen Risiken und
daher der Name hat es schon angedeutet
also es gibt nach wie vor
Nationalstaaten die sozusagen auch
ökonomisch auch zu ihrem eigenen Schaden
Maßnahmen setzen und Konkurrenten
sozusagen in Mitleidenschaft zu ziehen
oder ein Ziel zu erreichen und dazu
haben wir noch die Inflation und die
stadtflation die nicht überwunden sind
meine Damen und Herren
neben diesen Gruppen gibt es jetzt
natürlich zwei besondere die ich für
2023 hervorheben möchte weil sie aus
unserer Sicht sehr relevant sind und das
ist das erste ist ein Angriff auf einen
EU-Mitgliedstaat und zwar hat dies
natürlich der Ukraine massiv verstärkt
und es ist so ob das jetzt konventionell
oder unterhalb der Schwelle des
militärischen
gewaltmonimpuls passiert ist sozusagen
sekundär aber bei einer weiteren
Eskalierung wird Österreich
blitzartig in eine sicherheitspolitische
Herausforderung kommen die Konsequenz
wäre nämlich dass ein EU-Mitgliedstaat
die beistandpflicht nach Artikel 42 7
des EU-Vertrages aktivieren würde das
bedeutet wiederum Österreich müsste sie
sehr sehr rasch bezüglich
Beistandspflicht und Solidarität
Gedanken machen
daher wäre die zentrale Frage natürlich
sofort ist die irische Klausel
anzuwenden oder beteilen wir uns
solidarisch
eu-außen Verteidigung meine Damen und
Herren ein zweiter Punkt und ich
verbundsminister hat das schon kurz
angedeutet ist die Verschärfung der
militärstrategischen Risiken und hier
ist Österreich massiv einer Verschärfung
ausgesetzt das bedeutet es kann sein
dass wir mit uns mit einer
neutralitätswidrigen Nutzung als unsere
Staatsgebietes auseinandersetzen müssen
dass die Bedrohungen aus der Luft vor
allem durch Flugzeuge Drohnen und
Flugzeugen extrem hoch ist und das
wiederum parallel Begleiter durch
sogenannte Hybride Angriffe und Maßnahme
daher sind natürlich die
festgelegten Aufgaben der
Landesverteidigung zu landet in der Luft
im cyberraum und ihm Informationsraum so
wichtig dass diese sichergestellt werden
müssen
meine Damen und Herren zum Abschluss
auch ein zweiter positiver Aspekt dass
wir nicht nur sozusagen den negativen
Bereiche ansprechen ist das Ziel unserer
Arbeit ist es zum einen darzustellen was
uns entgegenkommt das zweite ist die
Konsequenzen daraus zu ziehen und das
dritte ist glaubwürdige Handlungen zu
setzen um den gegen zu wirken mit der
Aufstockung der finanziellen Mittel für
das Bundesheer durch die Bundesregierung
ist hier extrem rasch so eine Handlung
gesetzt worden das ist sozusagen aus
unserer Sicht äußerst positiv und ein
zweiter Aspekt der spricht auch ein
weiteres Risiko an das ist nämlich die
strategiefähigkeit eines Staates den
haben wir heute vielleicht initiiert mit
dieser Veranstaltung und mit diesem
Diskussionen die wir heute durchführen
meine Damen und Herren auch wenn die
Analysen eher negativ sind sollten wir
das sozusagen in einem positiven Aspekt
bringen dass wir es wissen und uns
darauf vorbereiten können und zum
Schluss möchte ich mich schon noch sehr
herzlich bei meiner Mitarbeitern
bedanken die unterjährig das alles
wissenschaftlich abarbeiten und vor
allem Silvia Angerbauer Hermann Maier
und Bernhard Richter die da unermüdlich
daran arbeiten dass wir Ihnen das heute
präsentieren können und dass sie daraus
vielleicht die richtigen Flüsse ziehen
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
vielen Dank an Herrn
Diskussion ist schon mehrfach
angesprochen worden das ist in wirklich
gelungen großartige Expertinnen und
Experten zu uns zu holen und ich darf
jetzt auch schon beginnen unsere Gäste
vorzustellen ich bitte zu uns
Botschafterin Salome Maiers ist seit
letzten Dezember gerade die neue
Botschafter in der Schweiz in Österreich
zuvor waren sie missionschefin sind sehr
gespannt auf ihre Perspektive auch auf
die Neutralität die unsere beiden Länder
durchaus unterschiedlich interpretieren
herzlich willkommen Frau Meier bitte
schön
[Applaus]
dann bitte ich zu uns Günther Hofbauer
ist schon angesprochen worden
generalmayr und Planung Chef des
österreichischen Bundesheeres
verantwortlich für dessen
Weiterentwicklung und da gibt es
offenbar so viel zu tun gerade wie
selten zu Form sie werden uns einen
Einblick in das neue
gefechtsbild bzw auch den Krieg der
Zukunft geben herzlich willkommen
Günther
[Applaus]
dann begrüßen wir sehr herzlich Franz
Stefan Gady Politikberater analystern
international Institute Institute von
international DJ studies in London
Regierung ein Streitkräfte in Europa in
den Vereinigten Staaten zu Themen
Strukturreform sie können sitzen möchten
sehr gerne nehmen Sie das jawoll
[Applaus]
ich wollte sagen sie beraten regieren
und Streitkräfte in Europa in den
Vereinigten Staaten zu den Themen
Strukturreform organisatorische die
doktrinelle Weiterentwicklung und auch
Zukunft das Kriege schön dass Sie da
sind dann auch das ist uns
zivilistren Zivilisten sehr bitter
bewusst geworden dieser Krieg hat die
Energie Sicherheit zumindest die
gefühlte für uns auf die Probe gestellt
Gerhard Christine ist jetzt vorstellen
dass Power Creed durch und damit
verantwortlich für die österreichischen
Stromnetze durch die unser aller Strom
fließt auch der den wir jetzt gerade
hier verwenden wenn es auch sehr
gespannt auf Ihre Einschätzung zu
Risiken bei den Energieversorgung bis
hin zu seilbahngriffen Black Hat
herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
und dann stelle ich Ihnen noch sehr
herzlich vor Ulrike Franke es ist vom
European Council auf Foreign Relations
es ist Expertin für deutsche
Verteidigungspolitik Technologie
Geopolitik sie sind uns zugeschaltet sie
sind auch Experte für Militärtechnologie
drohnenkrieg und wir möchten auch gerne
mit ihnen beginnen wir möchten gerne
auch für Sie hier im Publikum dass
unsere expertenexperten mal drei vier
Minuten die jeweilige Sicht auf die Welt
auf die Situation
darlegen Frau Franke jetzt die
Diskussion um die Lieferung Deutscher
kampfpanz in die Ukraine ist beendet
jetzt gibt es aber auch schon erste
zumindest mal ja inhaltliche
Diskussionen sollen denn da auch
Kampfflugzeuge in die Ukraine geschickt
werden die Vereinigten Staaten dürften
da ein wenig sich in die Diskussion ist
einbringen deutschland lehnt das ab
vorange ihre Sicht auf die Situation
eben auch jetzt unter dem Eindruck der
Waffenlieferungen ganz konkret der
Panzer in die Ukraine
gut hören freut mich sehr dass sie mich
hier zuschalten konnten aus London
naja also ich
würde sagen wir haben in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten doch eine relevante
Veränderung gesehen was die deutsche
Außen- und Verteidigung angeht
Deutschland vollzieht ja
angeblicherweise die die zeitenwände ich
betone immer dass der Bundeskanzler am
27 Februar als er eben von dieser
zeitmane gesprochen hat diese Zeiten
wenn er nicht ausgerufen hat sondern
eigentlich sie festgestellt hat und das
ist ein kleiner aber feiner Unterschied
denn innovative ist eigentlich zu sagen
es tut sich etwas in der Welt das
verändert sich etwas in der Welt und ähm
das müssen wir jetzt erstmal wahrnehmen
natürlich müssen wir auch auf reagieren
aber es war letztendlich eigentlich
nicht so ein
politikvorschlag irgendwie ist teilweise
dann hieß trotzdem ist es so dass eben
in Deutschland sich einiges getan hat
und Lieferung der Leopard Panzer ist
jetzt davon ein Teil und im übrigen uns
vielleicht um einfach von von
Deutschland da mal ein bisschen
wegzukommen weil das ja auch für
Österreich interessant ist was wir eben
auch ganz klar sehen ist dass sich in
der EU in Europa einiges getan hat denn
ich sage immer so schön Deutschland ist
der dritt wichtigste Unterstützer und
waffenlieferer an die Ukraine nach den
USA und Großbritannien aber eigentlich
ist Deutschland der vierte denn davor
kommen noch die EU-Institutionen und das
heißt die EU hat in diesem in diesem
Krieg in diesem Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine
schon eine sehr wichtige Rolle gespielt
die EU ist ein Akteur geworden der
plötzlich Militär Waffen finanziert das
ist gab es so auch noch nicht vorher
die
EU hat auch eine wahnsinnig wichtige
Rolle gespielt oder spielt das waren sie
die wichtige Rolle wenn es um
Wirtschaftssanktionen geht also wir
haben neuen Sanktion das Pakete die die
Russland
treffen und insofern also das ist da
zeigt sich schon dass ich so eine
Zeitenwende nicht nur vollzogen hat oder
vollzieht in in Deutschland aber auch in
der EU gleichzeitig ist das Glas
natürlich da nie nie ähm
voll sondern immer auch halb leer und es
ist eben so dass ja in in Deutschland
zeigt sich die Diskussion bleibt
schwierig die panzerdiskussion war jetzt
ehrlich gesagt auch kein Glanzstück der
deutschen politischen Diskussion und man
hat schon den Eindruck dass die deutsche
Regierung auch immer so ein bisschen
hinter
hinter hinter der Welle bleibt und alles
etwas zu zögerlich mache obwohl es ist
letztendlich doch macht und auch Europa
und die EU naja
tun zwar viel aber und das finde ich
einen ganz wichtiger Punkt jetzt auch
für unsere Diskussion es scheint immer
noch die Unterstützung und eigentlich
mehr noch das an die Hand nehmen durch
die USA zu brauchen und wenn ich jetzt
quasi so ein paar geopolitische
Trendlinien aufzeichnen müsste in der
Welt ist ist das genau einer davon
nämlich dass Europa immer noch nicht in
der Lage scheint wirklich
selbstbestimmt und souverän gewisse
Dinge zu regeln sondern das ist immer
noch den den amerikanischen großen
Bruder da braucht ich bin ein großer Fan
der transatlantischen Beziehung und
Freundschaft insofern grundsätzlich
finde ich das absolut richtig wenn der
Westen also Europa und die USA mit ein
paar anderen Partnern gemeinsam handeln
aber es macht mir doch sehr sorgen dass
diese ganze Idee der europäischen
Souveränität über die wir so häufig
sprechen doch davon abzuhalten scheint
das in weißen Haus ein
Präsident sitzt der ja uns eben mitnimmt
und uns an die Hand nimmt und
da sicher geht dass wir auch tatsächlich
das tun was wir was wir sollen und
eigentlich auch wollen dem wird auch
nicht immer so sein wir werden da nicht
immer einen Joe Biden sitzen haben und
insofern wäre meiner Pell an an Europa
die EU sich da stärker auch ja noch mal
intern solidieren und miteinander eben
zu zu äh
kommunizieren und zu zu agieren und da
ist meines Erachtens auch eine große
Herausforderung eben für Österreich als
ein neues eines der neutralen Länder in
innerhalb der EU da gibt's ja noch ein
paar andere auch wenn wir jetzt mit
Schweden und Finnland zwar Länder die
zwar nicht direkt neutral aber doch
zumindest allein wie man so schön sagt
waren ähm verloren hat da wird sich
meines Erachtens auch Österreich in den
nächsten Jahren starker positionieren
müssen weil die EU eben versuchen wird
in dem militärischen Bereich mehr zu
machen ich habe gerade gesagt sie macht
auch schon viel und hoffentlich auch
versuchen wird eben zum Thema Menschen
Souveränität sich da stärker zu
positionieren das heißt Neutralität ist
ich weiß nicht ob noch eine
Zukunftsthema ist sagen wir es mal so
[Applaus]
es gibt ja es gibt ja
es gibt vielleicht Zurückhaltung im
Publikum was dieses Thema betrifft aber
ja lassen wir das einfach mal so stehen
Frau Franke vielen Dank für ihre erste
Einschätzung jetzt mal kommen wir zu
Franz Stefan Gady wir haben doch jetzt
schon gehört in den Kinos ja gerade auch
da muss uns zum Beispiel in Österreich
klar werden dass wir im Krieg sind oder
an diesem Krieg irgendwie Teilnehmer
selbst dann auch wenn wir keine Uniform
tragen wie weg gehört haben wenn wir es
doch die Meldung aus dem Creme auf den
Entscheid der Lieferung der schweren
Panzer am Ende auf diese Meldungen
schauen dann sieht das natürlich Grimmel
der Gremien in Moskau sofort das Kriegs
Beteiligung wisst ihre Einschätzung der
Lage sind wir tatsächlich im Krieg bin
ich jetzt gerade im Krieg mit Russland
bevor ich die Frage beantwortet
selbstverständlich sind wir nicht im
Kriegszustand jetzt als Österreich oder
auch als Europäische
Union ich warne auch wirklich davor
Krieg und Frieden hier zu vermischen ich
weiß dieses Worte Hybriden Bedrohung ich
bin persönlich kein besonderer Fan davon
weil wir grundsätzlich glaube ich als
Militär aber auch als militäranalysten
an sich ein Kommunikationsproblem haben
meistens nicht nur mit Politikern
sondern mit der gesamten Gesellschaft
und zum Beispiel ein Begriff für hybride
Bedrohungen ist für mich relativ nichts
sagen die in der Hinsicht und das
vermischt vieles und wir müssen hier
immer sehr konkret sein glaube ich in
unseren Ansätzen und in unseren Analysen
aber das ist jetzt meine persönliche
Meinung
grundsätzlich jetzt der um die Frage zu
beantworten ich glaube wenn wir auf
unsere Streitkräfte hier in Österreich
blicken oder auch in Europa
gibt es zwei Ansätze darüber
nachzudenken oder sie auch aufzubauen
ein Ansatz ist man blickt auf die
streitkräfteentwicklung von einer
friedensperspektive
oder man blickt auf eine
streitkräfteentwicklung von einer
einsatz-perspektive oder
kriegsperspektive wie ich es nennen
würde mein Fokus in meiner Forschung ist
auf die hochintensive
kriegs-krieg während der Ukraine
stattfindet und was ist dafür für
Ableitungen gibt für die zukünftige
streitkräfteentwicklung in Europa und da
kann man natürlich von der Ukraine bis
jetzt leichte Ableitungen Durchführen
von der Lage wie sie im Moment sich
darstellt ich waren aber auch wiederum
voreiligen Schlüssen aber den Beitrag
den ich ihm geschrieben habe für die für
die
für diese Publikation jetzt da handelt
eben davon und er möchte vielleicht drei
schnelle Punkte runterbringen das eine
ist die Wichtigkeit des sogenannten
Kampfes der verbundenen waffens das habe
ich mal bezeichnet als eine Art
tödliches Ballett oder auch ähm
mörderisches steinschere Papier spielt
das ist einfach die Integration von
verschiedenen Plattformen und
Waffensystemen das ist enorm wichtig
nicht nur für die konventionelle
Entdeckung es ist quasi die
Königsdisziplin das ist quasi die
Champions League quasi alle
militärischen Disziplinen und das muss
das Bundesheer beherrschen und ich bin
auch ehrlich gesagt ein sehr großer Fan
jetzt der von diesem budgetären
Erhöhungen weil wir sind jetzt erstmals
wirklich
theoretisch fähig dass wir diesen Kampf
der verbundenen Waffen wirklich schaffen
in den nächsten Jahren also da müssten
wir alle optimistisch sein ich sehe da
wirklich also bin keiner der jetzt so
sagt okay wir haben diese Krisen wir
arbeiten da wirklich glaube ich in eine
richtig gute Richtung das wäre eine
Punkt der zweite Punkt annehmen den
Kampf der verbundenen Waffen
ist wenn man auf den Krieg in der
Ukraine jetzt der schaut dann ist eines
der
blutigen Tatsachen leider eben die
enormen Verluste an Menschen Material
nicht nur weil es ein abnutzungskrieg
ist sondern weil moderne hochintensive
Kriegsführung einfach nicht nur enorme
Verluste
verursacht sondern dies proportional
Verluste verursacht in den besten
militärverbänden unter den besten
Offizieren unter den besten Mannschaften
das sind jene Soldaten und Leute die dem
Land die im eigenen Land die als erstes
wahrscheinlich fallen werden was heißt
das jetzt im Umkreis von z.B für ein
Land wie Österreich das heißt wir müssen
fähig sein unsere Streitkräfte im
Ernstfall zu regenerieren wir brauchen
eine resiliente
Regenerationsfähigkeit das heißt nichts
anderes dass wir verstärkt auf unsere
Milizsystem schauen müssen wir müssen
verstärkt schauen dass wir dort gute
Leute anziehen wenn es das irgendwie im
Grund nicht möglich ist dass wir wieder
verpflichtende lebensübungen einführen
ich glaube persönlich das ist eine sehr
wichtige Sache dass dennoch irgendwie zu
tun wenn man das irgendwie durchboxen
könnte weil ich eigentlich wenig
Alternativen sehe
diese Regenerationsfähigkeit ist nicht
nur ein Problem in Österreich das ist
ein Problem in Deutschland die Reserve
bei uns heißt Miliz in anderen Ländern
heißt Reserve
aussuchen Miliz hat mir nie ganz
gefallen Reserve viel besser wenn man
das einführen könnten aber es ist jetzt
der belanglos in dieser Diskussion aber
ich glaube diese Regenerationsfähigkeit
ist enorm einfach wichtig und das sind
für mich die zwei Hauptpunkte die ich
vielleicht heute mitgeben will der Kampf
der verbundenen Waffen und die
Regenerationsfähigkeit der Streitkräfte
in einer hochintensiven Kriegsführung
muss gewährleistet sein nicht so sehr
dass wir eben einen Krieg irgendwann
einmal führen müssen sondern vielmehr
das wir nicht nur in Österreich sondern
auf europäische Unionsebene die
sogenannte konventionelle Abschreckung
steigern durch eine Stärkung der
konventionellen Abschreckung das ist wie
eine versicherungspolize verringen wir
auch das Risiko eines Krieges und das
ist etwas glaube ich wo es zum Beispiel
wieder darum geht das klar und deutlich
auch außerhalb unserer Community zu
kommunizieren danke sehr
Frau franke hat ja zuvor aber auch die
transatlantischen Beziehung angesprochen
die haben sie es gar nicht eingerechnet
das heißt das haben sie jetzt
ausschließlich aus europäischer und
natürlich österreichischer Sicht gesehen
ja also die strategische
Autonomität hat glaube ich einen
herumschlag erlitten in der letzten
Tagen durch die Aktion die jetzt in
Berlin stattgefunden hat also die Idee
dass ihm ein Land wie Deutschland das
eine Führungsrolle eigentlich
eingenommen sollte in dieser
strategischen autonomiedebatte innerhalb
Europas nicht den alleingangmarkt
Systeme zu schicken die in der Hinsicht
nicht das Gleiche Eskalationspotenzial
gehabt haben wie zum Beispiel die Panzer
2000 die die Deutschen schon geschickt
haben oder eben den Flugabwehr Panzer
Gepard der ja ein Panzer ist in
Wirklichkeit und das war ein klarer
deutscher Alleingang das ist für mich
problematisch und das wird natürlich
Konsequenzen haben und ich glaube
indirekt
und die direkte Konsequenz wird sein
dass jemand der NATO und an die
amerikanische konventionelle
Abschreckung in Europa
den nächsten zeige ich mir jetzt einmal
10 20 Jahren nicht vorbeigehen wird
Dankeschön dass ich dann Nachfassen
durfte Herr Hofbauer ich nehme gerne
Herrn gratis Worte auf die verbundenen
Kräfte das wäre jetzt wichtig für das
österreichische bundesheeren diese
Champions League quasi
aufzusteigen aber auch die Regeneration
wir sind denn ihre Einschätzungen zu den
Entwicklern am Gefechtsfeld wie sieht
denn für sie der Krieg der Zukunft aus
es wird
es wird hinten freigeschalten
das österreichische Bundesheer hat ja
doch
sich nie dem hingegeben dass wir uns so
spezialisiert hätten dass wir nur
Menschen abdecken können das
österreichische Bundesheer ist in der
Lage
grundsätzlich mit seinen Waffengattungen
und den Waffensystemen den Kampf der
verbundenen Waffen zu führen wo es
wo es hapert ist im Endeffekt das halt
hier auch die Fähigkeiten nur mehr sehr
kleinen vorhanden sind und nur mehr in
sogenannten einen rekonstruktionskern
abgebildet und das muss man jetzt
entsprechend wieder hoch führen wieder
hochfahren ich würde wenn man Richtung
Krieg der Zukunft denken hat natürlich
keiner von uns die Kristallkugel weil
dann wäre das alles eine einfache
Aufgabe und wir sind alle durch den 24.2
vorigen Jahres über zu meinem neudeutsch
geflasht gewesen sagen wir sind
schockiert überrascht dass so etwas
eintreten kann wir dürfen aber auch
nicht voreiligen Schlüssel ziehen dass
dieser Krieg in der Ukraine wie wir
jetzt sehen das rollenmodel für alle
weiteren Konflikte sein wird es gibt
eine politische strategische und
militärische Zeit nach der Ukraine wo
wir uns selbst bestmöglich darauf
vorbereiten müssen das heißt nicht dass
wir aber nicht gewisse Folgerungen aus
der Ukraine mitnehmen müssen und eines
ist einmal ganz wichtig es wird
schneller und es wird
mehr
es wird nicht einfacher werden die Räume
werden größer und die Streitkräfte sind
überschaubar groß 55.000 österreichische
Soldaten sind auf gar keinen Fall in der
Lage flächendeckend das ganze
Bundesgebiet zu schützen das heißt es
geht darum Kräfte darauf vorzubereiten
was auch die Technologie in Zukunft
hereinbringen wird nämlich das noch mehr
als bisher alles was aus dem
Gefechtsfeld sich bewegt erkannt wird
und innerhalb von kürzester Zeit auch
bekämpft wird das heißt wir müssen
unsere Kräfte auflockern und müssen Sie
unter Nutzung der digitalen
Möglichkeiten die Technologie ist ja
hier eben gerade im zivilen Bereich sehr
ausgeprägt so zum Einsatz bringen dass
sie verteilt
den Raum nutzen können aber zur
richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort
zusammengeführt werden können das ist
jetzt auch nichts neues das haben wir
schon ein König Krebs erlebt leider zu
unserem Nachteil aber die Dimension in
der sich das heute abspielt da reden wir
nicht mehr von Regiment an und
Heeresgruppen oder Kurs sondern da
sprechen wir von ganz kleinen Einheiten
die im Wesentlichen in der Lage sein
müssen hier auf dem effektsfeld ein
Lagebild zu bringen auf von ganz unten
jeder ist ein Sensor die Informationen
ganz nach oben zu bringen wo dann die
Entscheidungen getroffen werden in
meiner Perspektive auf die Jahre 2040 45
hin müssen wir uns auch überlegen dass
die Landstreitkräfte sicher nicht mehr
so geführt werden wenn es die
technischen Entwicklungen zulassen wie
wird das heute tun nämlich über viele
viele Führungsebenen die logischerweise
viel langsamer sind als wenn sie das
Vergleichen zum Beispiel wie
Luftstreitkräfte
geführt werden
dezentraler Einsatz unter einer
zentralen Führung was wir aber
jedenfalls aus der Ukraine mitnehmen
möchte ist nicht nur die Digitalisierung
und die Frage der Waffenwirkung des
unbestrittenen umfassenden Kampfs der
Teilzeitkräfte und das Kampfes der
verbundenen Waffen über die
verschiedenen Waffengattungen hinweg
sondern auch der Wert der Ausbildung
das Überleben das weiter kämpfen können
in verzweifelten lagen auch ohne
Verbindung oder unmittelbare
Auftragserteilung durch die vorgesetzte
Ebene das haben wir gerade in der
Anfangszeit des Ukraine Konfliktes
gesehen dass das ganz entscheidend ist
und es muss uns klar sein dass in einer
westlich demokratischen Gesellschaft wie
ein Führungssystem im Bundesheer auch
aufzubauen haben dass es den
Kommandanten aller Ebenen
Handlungsfreiheit gibt mir wer von der
Führung her in die Absicht investieren
und weniger in das Detail dadurch
Führung
die ganzen Herausforderungen die mit dem
verbunden sind wie lange muss man
ausbilden wie gut ist die Technik dazu
in der Unterstützung das ist ja zweite
Frage aber es muss uns klar sein dass
autoritäre Systeme ein anderes
führungsbild haben als demokratische
Systeme und das ist eine unserer
wesentlichen Stärken damit würde es mal
belassen danke
[Applaus]
kommen wir zu Ihrer Exzellenz zur
verwundschafterin in Salome Maier
es war sehr interessant dass hier auch
heute die geistige Landesverteidigung
bereits angesprochen wurde unser bei der
Länder sind neutral das eine Land
natürlich im Verbund der Europäischen
Union das andere außerhalb interessant
ist aber diese Wahrnehmung also in
Österreich wenn man sich natürlich jetzt
letztes Jahr geändert aber in Österreich
hat man oft gedacht wir sind neutral im
Sinne von wir spielen nicht mit und wenn
wir nicht mitspielen kann auch nicht
verlieren zum Glück die Schweiz sind
hier mit dran anders die ist jetzt sehr
für ihre werftigkeit wie reagiert die
Schweiz jetzt in diesem Lage die Mengen
als neutraler Stadt
ja vielen Dank
dass das Risiko Bild die Einführung des
Risiko Bild spricht von einer Situation
von Krieg jenseits von klauservice
und da stellt sich die Frage was ist die
Rolle eines neutralen Staates und die
diese Frage wird in der Schweiz sehr
intensiv debattiert ich kann Ihnen sagen
es gibt kein Tag an dem ich am Morgen
nicht die die Nachrichten höre wo diese
Frage in der alten oder anderen Weise
nicht angesprochen würde ist eine
gesunde Debatte und seine gesunde
Debatte eine intensive Debatte darüber
ob und wie Neutralität in den aktuellen
Lage oder in der neuen Realität
überhaupt noch Sinn macht angewendet
werden kann und soll es ist eine Frage
eine Diskussion über die
Neutralitätspolitik aber der
völkerrechtliche Status der Schweiz aus
neutraler Staat ist weiterhin breit
verankert in der Schweiz und das ist
wichtig diesen Unterschied
zu verstehen und sich dessen bewusst zu
sein in dieser Diskussion gibt es quasi
zwei Argumentationslinien oder die eine
sagt
angesichts dieses schockieren diese
schockierenden
ist die Bedeutung der Neutralität das
außenpolitisches Instrument wieder
gestärkt
quasi wie im 20 Jahrhundert wegen des
kalten Kriegs die Rolle als Vermittler
die guten Dienste als Plattform für
Verhandlungen ist die eine
Argumentationslinie die andere sagt ja
gut Neutralität die Welt von heute
unterscheidet sich maßgeblich von ihnen
das 20 Jahrhunderts im Kalten Krieg des
20 Jahrhundert ging es am Ende des Tages
um den Halt eines Status Quo von
einflussfähigen der Großmächte die der
heutige Kalte Krieg wenn man das so
nennen möchte
da geht es um disruption um die
Stabilisierung und wenn ein Akt der
Stabilisierung und disruption will und
sucht dann hat er kein Interesse an
Plattformen für Verhandlungen und
entsprechend ist die Neutralität die
oder der Neutralität in ein bisschen
geschmälert so also das ist das ist so
die Diskussion wenn wir von Neutralität
das Essen politisches Instrument
sprechen und ich bin Diplomatin nicht
militärexpertin
nun kann man fragen also gut in diesem
Spannungsfeld was ist die Relevanz der
Neutralität für ein Land wie die Schweiz
und ich muss sagen ich kann nur für die
Schweiz sprechen weil Neutralität ist
immer auch
eingebettet in einem geopolitischen
Kontext und einige politische Analyse
gerade weil unsere Neutralität
völkerrechtlich verankert ist haben wir
ein eigenes Interesse an einem
rechts an einen rechtsstaatlichen Welt
an eine
stabilen
rechtsbasierten Weltordnung und wir sind
gut positioniert als Schweiz uns für
dieses für den halt das Völkerrechts
einzusetzen insbesondere
Stadt wie ich finde durchaus erfolgreich
und effizient Sprichwort humanitäre
und dann das zweite Element hier
die das Ende der Geschichte dass wir
prophezeit bekommen anfangs 90er Jahre
das Ende der Geschichte ist nicht
eingetroffen oder und die Geschichte
lehrt uns der Moment der Gespräche kommt
und dann braucht es Akteure die
Plattformen bereitstellen können die
vermitteln können und die Schweiz ist
gut positioniert als neutrale Stadt ist
zu tun nicht aufgrund unseres
geopolitischen Einflusses den wir eben
nicht haben sondern auf unsere
Neutralität also ich würde argumentieren
die Neutralität auch wenn sie stark
kritisiert wird hat weiterhin Ihnen wert
als aus dem politischen Instrument aber
und was heißt glauben
die Neutralität ist nicht und war nie
Werte neutral
ität heißt militärische Neutralität aber
es ist nicht eine Welt ein
weltanschaulicher neutralismus und ich
zitiere hier einen österreichischen
Parlament weil und das bedeutet neutrale
Staaten müssen auch solidarisch sein
Punkt 1 Punkt 2 Neutralität bedeutet für
die Schweiz dass wir uns selber
verteidigen können
das heißt
Investitionen auch Investitionen in die
Rüstung und
investitions-würdig wenn wir uns
verteidigen können und der dritte Punkt
wir dürfen keine Sicherheitslücke sein
und das bedeutet wir müssen unsere
Verteidigung in alle breite die die Frau
Ministerin auch erwähnt hat wir müssen
die Verteidigung modernisieren
und wir müssen kooperieren
beispielsweise im Bereich Cyber
beispielsweise im Bereich ABC aber
durchaus auch zu Fragen der
Interoperabilität solange dies
neutralitätsrechtlich zugelassen sind
also unter diesen drei Bedingungen der
Glaubwürdigkeit hat die Neutralität Welt
und glaube ich auch vielleicht ein
bisschen gegen das Votums der Kollegen
der ersten Rednerin Zukunft vielen Dank
[Applaus]
vielen herzlichen Dank Botschaft an
seinem Mayer danke schön
kommen wir zu Ihnen Gerhard Christina
ja die Verb Bundesministerin wird sich
erinnern vor einiger Zeit gab es eine
blackout-kampagne und da weiß ich noch
was JournalistInnen Journalisten gesagt
haben Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
vollkommen übertrieben und überhaupt hat
sie damals geheißen das hat 24 Februar
dann plötzlich ganz anders gezeigt
plötzlich haben wir auch verstanden dass
tatsächlich der Strom nicht einfach nur
aus der Steckdose kommt und es ist sehr
gut dass Sie hier sind Herr Christina
sie sind quasi verantwortlich für die
Österreicher Stromnetze durch die unter
Strom fließt wie ist denn da jetzt die
Lage ganz neutral betrachtet gibt's da
Blackout Gefahr gibt es Strom Mangel
lagen das wird nicht immer gleich
kommuniziert bitte um ihre Einleitung
warte
ja ich glaube eines ist klar der Krieg
in der Ukraine hat
energiewirtschaftlich aber auch
energiepolitisch das muss man ganz offen
sagen das ist eine Zäsur das wird nicht
mehr so werden wie es war das muss uns
klar sein und ich glaube wir alles sind
daran oder müssen daran interessiert
sein Europa als Ganzes aber auch
Österreich dass wir uns von dieser
extremen Abhängigkeit aus dieser
fossilen Abhängigkeit die wir aus
Russland haben dass wir uns hier in
jedem Fall jetzt in den nächsten Monaten
Jahren diversifizieren dass wir neue
Partner suchen dass wir Lieferquellen
diversifizieren und auch die Lieferwege
entsprechend diversifizieren ich glaube
das ist aber ganz ganz wichtig weil das
was wir jetzt vorhatten auch wir wir
haben hier die Energiewende eingeleitet
auch in Europa auch in Österreich aber
diese Energiewende ist im Prinzip so
aufgebaut in Richtung 100% Erneuerbare
mal zu gehen im Strombereich aber Gas
als die Brückentechnologie zu verwenden
und gerade dieses das ist jetzt
sozusagen der Problemfaktor geworden das
heißt wir müssen auch diesen Weg diesen
Prozess völlig neu denken
wenn wir Österreich heute ansehen
natürlich war das letzte Jahr speziell
der Herbst dann von der großen Sorge
geprägt ob wir es überhaupt über diesen
Winter schaffen wie schaut es mit den
Gasreserven aus Österreich nur in einen
Gefühl zu geben ist im Winter zu circa
16% auch in der Stromversorgung von
gasabhängig wie importieren ca 20% Strom
auch im Winterhalbjahr und der Rest
kommt dann eben noch aus den
Erneuerbaren speziell Wasserkraft und
zum Teil auch im Winter Photovoltaik das
heißt wir müssen schauen dass wir genau
hier für diesen Prozess was die
Stromversorgung betrifft für die
Gaskraftwerke dass wir hier entsprechend
eine andere Lieferquellen haben weil
auch so ehrlich muss man sein das werden
wir nicht von heute auf morgen lösen
also der Weg in Richtung erneuerbare ist
natürlich vorgegeben das ist keine Frage
aber wir brauchen thermische Kraftwerke
zu Stabilisierung des Stromsystems des
Stromnetzes weil wir es einfach derzeit
nicht schaffen in Zeiten wo eben kein
Wind geht oder keine Sonne scheint und
das ist beispielsweise heute ein Tag
dazu da braucht man einfach andere
Einheiten noch um über den Winter oder
über diese Phasen zu kommen
nichtsdestotrotz
die Frage natürlich Blackout oder nicht
oder Strom Mangel Lage die Sie
angesprochen haben ich glaube da muss
man sehr wohl differenzieren eine
strommangelage wie sie das rohpotenzial
im Herbst war ist insofern für uns ich
sage jetzt einmal angenehmer als die
prognostizierbar ist also wir haben
einen Stresstest gemacht wir haben die
verschiedensten Risiko Parameter diese
Europa gegeben hat in diverse Szenarien
eingebaut und haben analysiert wie
könnte sich Europa und damit auch
Österreich für diesen Winter würde
könnte sich die Lage darstellen und zum
Glück muss man heute sagen haben sich
viele Parameter kritische Parameter
nicht in der Form bewahrheitet wie wir
sie auch ein teilweise angenommen haben
sprich der Atomkraft in Frankreich ist
mehr verfügbar als erwartet es ist die
Gasspeicher sind doch voll geworden und
wir wir alle wissen vielleicht das
klimatechnischer Sicht unangenehm aber
wir haben eine sehr warmen Winter der
hat natürlich massiv geholfen und die
Gastsprecher in Österreich sind noch um
die 80 Prozent 70 80 Prozent gefüllt ist
aber was was keiner erwartet hat so
gesehen ist dies der Aspekt der
Strommangel eigentlich die Sorge dass
wir in diesem Winter keinen Strom mehr
haben und die vielleicht im schlimmsten
Fall sogar ein flächenabschaltungen
gehen müssten was auch sozusagen in
einer Energielenkung denkbar wäre das
alles vorbereitet wurde auch mit dem
Ministerium das kann man die Faktor für
diesen Winter aus österreichischer Sicht
und glaube auch aus europäischer Sicht
ausschließen ein Blackout aus unserer
Sicht ist etwas für uns völlig
unerwartet ist ein ein Elementarereignis
ein störungsereignis und da muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen wir betreiben in
diesem Stromsystem ein hochtechnisches
hochkomplexes System das über ganz
Europa reicht da direkt
das ist die komplexeste Maschine dieser
Welt diese Stromsystem
und das so ein System kollabieren kann
dass es durch eine eine Störung wie
immer diese Störung verursacht wurde
durch Wetterereignisse durch einen
Lawinenabgang durch das also das kann
passieren das ist gar keine Frage und
wenn Sie mich fragen wann wird das
passieren das kann morgen passieren das
können wir in der Woche passieren das
kann aber auch nicht passieren also das
ist das ist einfach die Tatsache und ich
kann nur sagen um Ihnen vielleicht
insofern natürlich die Angst zu nehmen
wir haben natürlich top Experten in
diesem Gebiet bei uns die die
Betriebsführung machen wir haben auch
natürlich die Verpflichtung hier alles
zu tun um seinen Black Hat abzuwehren
das tun wir auch und das wichtigste
glaube ich für die Black Hat Vorsorge
ist die Tatsache dass wir es verstehen
in Österreich und in Europa diesen Weg
diese Transformation in Richtung 100%
Erneuerbare mit sehr viel Bewusstsein
Systemverständnis zu gehen dann ist auch
das Blick hat riesiger sehr gering ich
vergleiche das immer ein bisschen wie
mit uns Menschen das wäre so das wird
mir jeden Tag sehr ungesund Essen und
uns vor dem Herzinfarkt oder vor dem
Schlaganfall fürchten nicht das ist
irgendwie das eine verursachte das
andere und darum müssen wir auch schauen
dass wir eigentlich diese
Transformationsprozess so gestalten und
die richtigen Maßnahmen präventiv setzen
im Umbau des Systems setzen damit du das
Risiko des Black hast möglichst
minimieren würden wir nichts tun würden
wir so weiter ich sage das mal wurscht
wie wir es teilweise machen jetzt bei
dieser Energiewende Dinge bauen
ich sage jetzt einmal teilweise
Windparks bauen bevor die Stromnetze da
sind Stromnetze überlasten Stromhandel
zulassen über Regionen wo dann wir fast
tagtäglich mit Engpässen zu kämpfen
haben wenn wir das relativ fahrlässig
weiterfahren dann ist das Risiko sehr
wohl da dass es irgendwann diesen black
gibt
das klingt
[Applaus]
und auch da ein bisschen nachzufassen
das klingt dann jetzt wenn man es das
Thema Gas und Russland weil rausnimmt
dann scheint eine Gefahr eigentlich erst
im Innern zu kommen wenn ich zum
Beispiel eben Windparks für sie
anspreche
baue bevor ich dir dazugehörigen
Stromnetze das heißt hier könnten wir
selbst ein bisschen auch das Problem
werden und hier Probleme bei der
Stromversorgung offensichtlich selbst
sogar kreieren ich glaube das Problem
das muss man ganz offen ansprechen das
ist schon am Tisch es ist einfach so sie
brauchen nur teilweise zu den
Privathaushalten gehen man baut sich
Photovoltaikanlagen ganz Dach und kann
dann den Strom nicht einspeisen ins Netz
weil die nicht Infrastruktur nicht da
ist das muss ich jetzt aber auch ganz
klar sagen das ist nicht geschuldet im
Netzbetreiber es ist einfach geschuldet
der Tatsache dass wir eine Energiewende
haben die eigentlich keinem echten Plan
hinterfolgt aber wir haben sehr
ehrgeizige Ziele uns gesetzt bis 2030
noch ehrgeizige bis 20 40 aber einen
konkreten Plan wie wir diese Ziele
erreichen nämlich mit einem sehr gut
abgestimmten Ausbau der wunderbaren
gepaart mit einem Netzausbau gepaart mit
Speichertechnologien die enorm wichtig
sein werden dieses Verständnis zumindest
dieses unser Eindruck sehr oft in der
Branche ist nicht da und es ist
natürlich sehr opportun erneuerbare
auszubauen aber wenn es dann in
Netzinfrastruktur geht die natürlich
sehr oft von den Menschen dann eher als
sozusagen nicht gewollt gesehen wird
dann wird sehr sehr schwierig und
speziell die Genehmigungsverfahren hier
muss man echt synchron Arbeiten es kann
nicht sein dass die Leitung zehn Jahre
dauert der Windpark in zwei Jahren da
steht das sind Probleme an der müssen
jetzt arbeiten
[Applaus]
vielen Dank auch an sie für diesen
Einblick Frau Franke kommen wir wieder
zu ihnen sie haben da ja schon ja sehr
leidenschaftlich sage ich mal das Thema
transatlantische Beziehungen
aufgegriffen und ich habe sie verstanden
als eine Art plädoy jedes jetzt hier
spätestens jetzt die Europäische Union
selbstständig werden sollen wenn wir
jetzt allerdings wir machen chinesische
das chinesische Thema hier auch ein
bisschen angesprochen am wärst du nicht
trotzdem schlauer wenn das der drohende
Konflikt ist zwischen den USA und China
dann aus europäischer Sicht zumindest
vorläufig sehr wohl es sich mit den
Amerikanern gut zuständig ist das viel
zu naiv von mir gedacht
ich bin der Meinung dass eine enge
Beziehung zu den Vereinigten Staaten
absolut essentiell ist ich will auch
absolut keine Lanze brechen für ein
irgend wie geartetes die kapling von den
USA für mich ist diese ganze Idee der
europäischen Souveränität Autonomie der
gibt's ja verschiedene Begriffe da geht
es nicht darum sich irgendwie von den
USA abzuwenden oder auch nur
unabhängig zu machen weil man irgendwie
nicht mehr mit den USA zusammenarbeiten
will das ist absolut nicht der Punkt der
Punkt ist das Europa in der Lage sein
muss eigenständig Entscheidungen zu
treffen zum einen würde ich jetzt
einfach mal ganz grundsätzlich sagen
weil wir
27 oder wenn Sie die anderen Länder mit
reinnehmen 30 plus Länder sind mit 500
Millionen Menschen warum wir eigentlich
so stark an den USA hängen mit ihren 350
Millionen Menschen ist ist schon erstmal
eine Grundsatzfrage aber viel wichtiger
als auch einfach dass ich in den USA ja
sehr viel verändert es ist nicht klar
wer im nächsten Weißen Haus sitzen wird
und ob das jemand ist der so stark die
europäische europäischen Interessen im
Blick haben wird wie Joe Biden das jetzt
er macht selbst die übrigen wenn es
keine Republikaner ist jetzt aller
Trumps sondern auch ein Demokrat der
vielleicht mehr nach innen guckt die
Amerikaner haben genug innenpolitische
Probleme insofern also für mich ist es
eigentlich ein Punkt das eben Europa
grundsätzlich in der Lage sein soll da
da mehr zu tun und da geht die Reise ja
auch hin also der Punkt ist ja das ist
ja jetzt nicht erst seit dem
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine ein Thema
sondern diese diese Thematik
europäischen Souveränität und Autonomie
das wird ja schon lange durch ein
bisschen durch den Raum und gewisse
Schritte werden ja gemacht auch wenn ich
sehr mit von stadi da wäre das jetzt
eigentlich gerade so diese diese
Kommunikation aus dem dem deutschen
Kanzleramt in den letzten Wochen da dem
schon ein sehr schweren Schlag gegeben
hat für mich ist aber ein Punkt ganz
wichtig und ich finde es ganz
fantastisch dass sie sich die Schweizer
Sicht geholt haben heute denn diese
neutralitätsfrage wird meines Erachtens
in den nächsten Jahren viel mehr auf den
aufs Parkett kommen und der Punkt und
ich denke das wird ein Thema sein für
Österreich ist Österreich ist stärker
unter Druck was seine Neutralität angeht
als die Schweiz und das hat einfach mit
der EU-Mitgliedschaft zu tun denn die
Schweiz zum einen wäre es ja gehört die
ihre Realität ist völkerrechtlich
verankert als sowas aber die Schweiz ist
eben auch nicht in der EU und ist in der
Tat dann eben ja so ein online und und
hat eben bestimmte Verträge ist der
verstimmte Beträge Verträge Person nicht
eingegangen Österreich ist nun mal ein
Mitglied innerhalb der europäischen
Union und es gibt Leute und ich würde
mich eigentlich dazu zählen die sowieso
schon sagen ist es eigentlich schon
schwierig sich als neutral zu bezeichnen
wenn man in der Europäischen Union ist
denn stimmt die Europäische Union ist
kein Militär Bündnis aber die
Europäische Union geht zunehmend auch
hin eben als Verteidigungsbündnis
wahrgenommen werden zu wollen und da was
zu machen und wir haben ja den von Ihnen
sicherlich allseits bekannten Artikel
42.7 die europäische Art des NATO der
NATO beistandsklausel Artikel 5 das ist
ähm eine eine eine
verteidigungsklause da ist die Idee wenn
einer angegriffen wird dann helfen die
anderen
denjenigen das muss nicht militärisch
sein aber man sieht eben schon mit
gefangen ist mit gehangen da sind da
sind eben alle schon drin und Österreich
im macht sich da aktuell noch einen
recht schlanken Fuß und ähm sagt
offiziell inoffiziell so etwas in die
Richtung wie wenn wir angegriffen werden
wollen jetzt zwar verteidigt werden aber
wenn die anderen angegriffen werden
halten wir es eigentlich uns vorzusagen
wir sind neutral ich glaube das wird
zunehmen bisschen schwieriger ich glaube
der Druck auf Österreich wird da wird da
wird da steigen oder vor allen Dingen
auch letzter Satz Österreich im
spezifischen innerhalb der Gruppe der
sogenannten neutralen Länder innerhalb
der EU es sind ja eigentlich sechs
Finnland und Schweden kann man da schon
eigentlich nicht mehr reinziehen jetzt
zählen jetzt mit dem mit dem
bevorstehenden Natrup Beitritt dann
haben wir noch Irland Zypern und Malta
und der Punkt ist halt Irland ist
geographisch einfach nicht so relevant
ich glaube da wird man sich nicht so
sehr darauf konzentrieren und Zypern und
Malter sind einfach von der Größe und
und allem relativ irrelevant deswegen
glaube ich tatsächlich dass wenn wir
eine Neutralität Debatte in Europa
bekommen und ich erwarte dass das mehr
zum Thema wird dass da der Druck auf
Österreich steigen wird insofern kann
ich dann nur empfehlen sich mit dieser
Frage noch mal intensiv
auseinanderzusetzen zu überlegen wie man
sich da stellt zum Beispiel eben mit
Hinblick auf 42 7 mit Hinblick auf die
ganze Idee der EU Verteidigungsunion die
ja zunehmend gepusht wird und ja denke
ich auch zu Ihnen kommen wird
[Applaus]
also
Verfahren eine erneute oder überhaupt
eine neutralitätsdebatte in Österreich
auf uns zukommen der Christine würde mir
vermutlich recht geben das hält sich mit
der Neutralität so wie mit Atomkraft in
Österreich wir wollen es nicht jetzt
gerade importieren aber gerade Atomstrom
vermutlich an einer so dunkelblau wie
jetzt gerade würden sie da etwas
ergänzen wollen zu der Debatte die hier
wir machen jetzt keine
neutralitätsdebatte aber zu dem was Frau
Frank hier gesagt hat dass Österreichs
Rolle hier
hinterfragt werden wird in der Zukunft
Rieke hat ein paar gute Punkte hier
angeführt ich glaube nicht dass ich noch
mehr dazu sagen kann ich glaube eine
grundsätzliche Frage an sich ist
[Musik]
wie wir uns in Zukunft dann wirklich
auch einbinden werden auf europäischer
Ebene bzw was wir konkret auch an
militärischen Fähigkeiten beisteuern
wollen
sollte es wirklich mal darauf
hinauslaufen dass eu-direktoren
angegriffen wird es gibt ja verschiedene
Optionen und wie gesagt ich glaube da
muss man dann auch wirklich jede
einzelne Situation dementsprechend
beurteilen ich glaube eine
Pauschalverurteilung oder mit der
Analyse würde ich ja wenig Sinn machen
ich möchte nur vielleicht ein Punkt
mitgeben
hier geht es ja um Zukunftsszenarien und
so weiter ich glaube der grundsätzliche
Fehler und das sind wirklich alle in der
Analysten Community nicht File von ist
eben dass wir oft probieren dass die
Situation unseren Plänen sich anpasst
anstatt dass der Plan sich der Situation
anpasst also es ist oft ein Wunschdenken
dass quasi auch auf strategischer Ebene
stattfindet und nicht nur aus dem Grund
weil Österreich z.B oder auch
Deutschland in der sogenannten
strategischen Tiefe innerhalb der
Europäischen Union liegt und daher
konventionell jetzt nicht zu bedroht ist
wie andere Länder im Osten man denkt nur
die Wochen vor Ausbruch des Krieges in
der Ukraine eben was dort in die
politische Führung gemacht hat bzw nicht
gemacht hat und wenn ich vielleicht
einen Punkt den Gästen hier mitgeben
kann ist das englische Schriftsteller
hat 1945 war noch hier in Wien
geschossen wurde
am Donaukanal und so weiter ein Essay
geschrieben das hat er genannt in front
of you knows also was übersetzt auf der
Nasenspitze und einem ESC hat er darüber
geschrieben wie in den 30er und 20er
Jahren jeder quasi gewusst hat der
irgendetwas verstanden hat von
Militärpolitik Verteidigungspolitik in
Großbritannien das Hongkong und Singapur
enorm verwundbar sind ja und für 20
Jahre lang hat man da quasi einen
Wunschdenken ist mir danach gegangen hat
irrsinnig komische Strategien entwickelt
und und Papiere und es gab dann auch die
bekannte
zehnjahres kriegsregel weil man hat
probiert nach nach dem Ende des Ersten
Weltkriegs eine
Friedensdividende im Einzelverfahren
Churchill war damals der Finanzminister
gesagt wir reduzieren unsere
Militärausgaben und so weiter und hat
dann eben diese 10 Jahre Regel
eingeführt das heißt also wenn jetzt der
generalstoff mir sagt wir müssen in zehn
Jahren kein Krieg führen das heißt wir
können quasi mit unseren militärischen
Fähigkeiten runterfahren und das würde
jeden Tag wurde das erweitert ja wo
diese dieses Lagebild sich nicht
verändert hatte ja und warum
zurückkommen will ist aber die ganze
Zeit während dieser Zeit gab es
natürlich die Aufrüstung in Deutschland
Japan und so weiter und George Owen und
da komme ich wieder zurück in das Sea
von George Orwell sagt ihm das aller
schwierigste m in flanne 4 nose das
aller schwierigste ist eben genau das
was direkt auf der Nasenspitze sieht
zwar genau wenn also wenn Sie das jetzt
probieren ganz schwierig zum sehen was
da ist und die offensichtlichsten
Bedrohungen sind nämlich die Bedrohungen
die wahrscheinlich die sind die wir dann
oft auch übersehen und da lade ich mir
dazu ein oft ein bisschen vielleicht ja
von einer anderen Perspektive auch die
Sachen anzuschauen
danke
[Applaus]
es war letztes Jahr am österreichischen
Energiekongress Joschka Fischer der
ehemalige deutsche Bundesaußenminister
zu Gast und das ist sehr intensiven Rede
sie waren auch daher Christina danach
gemeint wenn man vor dem das nicht
vorwerfen kann dann dass er mit seinen
Absichten Hinterberg gehalten hätte gut
ähm Herr Hofbauer sie haben fahren wir
Ausbildung angesprochen
wir haben eben auch über ja die geistige
Landesverteidigung gesprochen es gibt
zahlen und ich denke das ist ein
bisschen anders in der Schweiz aber in
Österreich und Deutschland sagen auch
Umfang da ist man eigentlich nicht
wirklich bereit jetzt das Land auch
theoretisch mit der Waffe zu verteidigen
ähm was könnte man da denn jetzt ändern
also dass ich jetzt in der Jugend auch
nicht wirklich die Bereitschaft okay gut
ähm ich gehe jetzt zum Bundeswehr weil
das ist mein Anliegen was können was
können Sie von Ihrer Seite tun
ja die verbindungsministerin hat sich
schon ein bisschen angetönt in ihrer
Ansprache das sind im Endeffekt ist
schon darauf ankommt hier einen
umfassenden gesamtstaatlichen Ansatz zu
wählen das Bundesheer und das Militär
sind ja nicht selbst Zweck wir sind da
weil wir einfach da sein wollen weil
meine Auftrag und der Auftrag ist
natürlich Österreich entsprechend zu
verteidigen und wir verteidigen auch
nicht nur ein geografisches Gebilde
sondern es geht im Endeffekt darum dass
wir eigentlich für unsere Werte
einstellen müssen und das ist im
Endeffekt notwendig dass allen
österreichischen Staatsbürger nochmal
klar gemacht wird für welche Werte
stehen wir denn überhaupt dass es bei
uns möglich ist jederzeit zu
demonstrieren in jedem Medien alles zu
sagen alles zu tun
und trotzdem in Freiheit weiterleben zu
können und das ist jedenfalls etwas was
es zu verteidigen gilt und da geht es
auch darum dass wir schon 30 Jahre
Frieden und schon ein bisschen in einer
wohlfühlsituation finden wiederfinden
und das plötzlich überrascht sind dass
hier Krisensituationen auftreten die
nicht irgendwo stattfinden in
Afghanistan in der Sahelzone alles weit
weg sondern plötzlich ein
Kriegszustand näher ist als der
Atlantikküste oder die Grenze zu dem
Land wo wir kriegen näher ist als
Bregenz und da müssen wir denke ich
gemeinsam
der Gesamtstaat Weiterkommen über die
Ausbildung dass auch wir die Jugend
mitnehmen und in einer normal auch klar
machen dass hier die Dinge quasi nicht
vom Himmel fallen und Gott gegeben sind
und auch nicht immer unveränderbar
bleiben müssen und somit der klares Blut
für die Wiederbelebung der umfassenden
Landesverteidigung auch in diesem
Bereich was auch für den
wirtschaftlichen Bereich genauso gilt
die würde aber noch ganz gerne etwas
anfügen aus dem Vorrednern wo es nämlich
also die Stimme mit Internet
ist ja nicht ordentlich erklärt worden
aber ich denke es ist eine ordentliche
Auseinandersetzung damit was wir in den
letzten Jahren erlebt haben und was wir
alles nicht gesehen haben und nicht
sehen wollten schon angesagt dass und
hohe voll übereinstimme
Notes wir sind nicht vorbereitet wir
haben es zugelassen dass die europäische
Rüstungsindustrie einen
uns für eine Situation stellt dass wir
jetzt nicht mehr rasch aufrüsten können
die europäischen Streitkräfte sind auf
expeditionary operations vorbereitet
waren auf nischenfähigkeiten auf Einsatz
nicht zur konventionellen
Landesverteidigung und 2014 hat die NATO
begonnen das zu drehen mit dem Gipfel
von Wales und die Drehung war was sehr
langsam und die Überraschungen vorher
war auch bei den NATO-Staaten sehr groß
und wir sind im Endeffekt alle nicht
vorbereitet und wir können nur hoffen
dass sie im Wesentlichen aus dem was wir
jetzt ableiten erkennen strategische
Autonomie der EU ist ein wesentlicher
Faktor es Militär und streitkräfteplaner
können nur sagen es gibt keine
europäischen verteidigungsplanungen die
gibt es nicht es gibt viele gute
Dokumente die beziehen sich auf out of
area Einsätze außerhalb des
vertragsgebiets weil die Masse und die
vorrätinnen hat das sehr deutlich gesagt
überhaupt kein Interesse daran hat das
zu duplizieren weil für sie die NATO die
Verteidigung ist und die stimme zu dass
das eine wesentliche Herausforderung für
das österreichische Bundesheer in der
Zusammenarbeit mit unseren
internationalen Partnern auch darstellt
[Applaus]
ich möchte aber gerne beim Thema Hybride
Bedrohungen gleich bleiben nur zwei
Gedanken die mir es nicht Experten
einfallen wir haben es jetzt ich glaube
die Verbund Bundesminister hat das auch
schon angesprochen die Handelsketten die
gestört wurden durch die Pandemie noch
ist uns aber China durchaus freundlich
gestimmt also ein größerer Konflikt
womöglich zwischen den großen Systemen
ich denke nicht dass Europa vorbereitet
wir haben jetzt Medikamenten Probleme
weil das sehr sehr viel in Asien
produziert wird das könnte eine
Bedrohung sein und was dann vielleicht
auch in Richtung Herrn geht es war ja
letztes Wochenende
eine Koranverbrennung in Stockholm
darauf findet die Türkei sehr harsch
reagiert ist ja gerade der Natur
Ratifizierungsprozess für Schweden und
Finnland und der türkische Präsident
aufgrund dieser Koranverbrennung da kann
sie die Schweden plötzlich nicht in der
Natur es gibt es Gerüchte dass das
womöglich von russlandfreundlichen
Menschen auch noch eingeleitet werden
sollte also wer das Herr Garde so eine
Hybride Bedrohung über die wir ganz
konkreter sprechen müssen jetzt nur an
diesem Beispiel so ist denn stimmt
Schweden NATO Türkei
mein Problem mit dem Begriff Hybride
Bedrohungen ist einfach ein
Kommunikationsproblem oder ein
kommunikatives und vor allem
hat für viele Jahre in Europa und das
ist das Hauptproblem wurde Hybride
Bedrohungen dazu benutzt eben um quasi
die Abrüstung der konventionellen
militärischen Fähigkeiten eben
zu rechtfertigen also wir brauchen mehr
gibt keine konventionellen Krieg mehr es
gibt ein bisschen
informationskriegsführung selber
Kriegsführung was Gott noch was ja diese
ganzen Sachen aber für mich war immer
klar dass konventionelle Bedrohung plus
das information plus Cyberangriffe plus
politische Kampagnen und so weiter das
ganze das gesamte Spektrum ist dann
quasi zusammengefasst unter Hybriden
Bedrohungen und wir haben einfach gesagt
Hybride Bedrohungen das bedeutet wir
brauchen keine Artillerie Bataillon mehr
jetzt z.B oder keine Panzer das ist mein
Problem mit der Sache und das stimmt
einfach nicht der eigentliche
eigentliche Ausdruck der hybriden
Bedrohungen würde von einem von einem
Kollegen von mir 2006 entworfen also
Hybride Krieg eigentlich und da ist es
konkret im konventionelle Fähigkeiten
gegangen und nicht um die anderen Sachen
das sind quasi Addons das ist mein
Problem mit dem Begriffe da glaube ich
aber wird der Herr Hofbauer mit ihnen
mehr übereinstimmen also selbst denkt
das war ja tatsächlich so wie Herr
gerade sagt ah da gibt es die Hybride
Bedrohung ich brauche eigentlich jetzt
mehr ich brauche drunter ich brauche
jetzt mehr it Experte und Experten ich
brauche es keine Panzer mehr das haben
wir ja auch in Österreich erlebt hey
Hofbauer dieser Turner round ist ah zu
schaffen und B sind strategische
Autonomität angesprochen aber wenn man
an China denkt also wenn das so ist wie
sie sagen verteidigungspläne was
europäisches territoren betrifft ja dann
werden wir ganz andere Pläne auch nicht
haben oder welches denken wäre hier
notwendig passiert das jetzt auch schon
das ist etwas was auf der auf der
strategischen Ebene im Wesentlichen
zwischen den europäischen Staaten und
den den Organisationen in Brüssel
ordentlich weiterentwickelt werden muss
offensichtlich ist der Druck noch nicht
groß genug die die Frage wie sich die
USA in weiteren Jahren aus mit Europa
auseinandersetzen ist offen aus meiner
Sicht wir beobachten seit
Obama ganz klar dass ich das hinwenden
Richtung Pazifik und dass wir wenn wir
die Streitkräfte der USA betrachten ist
das ganz klar dass sich die doktrinär
ausrüstungsmäßig auf den Krieg im
Pazifik und hätte in Europa vorbereiten
was Sie jetzt tun ist dass sie im
Endeffekt die Ukraine und die Europäer
nach wie vor über die NATO unterstützen
das heißt da gibt es sehr viele Dinge
noch zu tun was wir als Militär
sicherstellen können und auch es
Österreicher Unabhängigkeit davon was
ein eine Streit Macht eines neutralen
Landes machen kann ist voll dann auf
interoperativität zu setzen das heißt
keine Insel Lösungen zu machen sondern
das wir rüstungsgut aber auch vor allem
im Denken und in dem wie wir die Dinge
tun mit anderen Streitkräften
bestmöglich zusammenarbeiten können und
ich kann es nur noch mal betonen es wird
eine Zeit kommen nach der Ukraine wo wir
unter Umständen wieder anderen
vermutlich auch außerhalb Europas an
anderen Krisen zu nagen haben und dort
militärische Aufgaben erfüllen und da
gibt's dann wieder multinational
entsprechend zusammenarbeiten und es
können durchaus härtere
Auseinandersetzungen sein als die die
wir derzeit im Kosovo in Bosnien oder
selbst im Chat mit den
ausbildungsmissionen sind also da ist
schon ein bisschen Kritik raus was die
europäischen Institution an betrifft ist
da vielleicht die Schwerpunktsetzung ein
bisschen falsch gelegt ich denke jetzt
daran wir möchten sehr sehr gerne den
Schwerverkehr auf die Schiene bringen
wir schaffen es aber nicht die
europäischen Bahngesellschaften und
einen Hut zu bringen ich stelle mir
diese Verteidigung sogar noch
schwieriger vor ist der Fokus vielleicht
in Brüssel ein bisschen falsch gesetzt
es ist gut wenn man Strohhalme verbieten
um um um um den Klima Gutes zu tun aber
die europäische Verteidigung darf man
auch nicht außen vorlassen wer bin ich
um Brüssel hier der Ratschläge zu geben
aber vielleicht nehmen wir uns nur ein
ein bisschen den Blick ein bisschen
weiter zurück auf gar nichts dann der
Abzug
wo war Europa es hat ja nicht einmal
also zumindest nicht dass ich es
mitbekommen hätte eine kurzfristige
Diskussion darüber geben dass ja Amerika
gut ihr zieht ab wir bleiben
wäre auch eine Option gewesen ich glaube
aber dass dazu keine politische
Diskussion zumindest nicht so
stattgefunden hätte dass man die gemerkt
hätte das sind ja auch Dinge die
wahrgenommen werden das muss uns doch
klar sein dass wenn wir solche
Entscheidungen treffen dass wir erstens
als Anhängsel der USA gesehen werden und
andererseits auch alle die die mit uns
verbündet sind sich überlegen müssen ob
sie in Zukunft noch mit uns so arbeiten
können wie davor erklärt vielleicht auch
manche Dinge die gerade in Afrika
vorgehen
und die Einflussnahmen die dort durch
andere kurz zu einem Christina kommen
weil sie ja vorhin so ein bisschen
durchblicken habe lassen
ich nehme nochmal dieses Beispiel der
Windpark steht schneller als die dazu
notwendige am Stabilität oder Netz
Versorgung ist man das so ein bisschen
schon zu optimistisch ich möchte niemand
etwas Schlimmes unterstellen aber ist
mir der europäischen Politik vielleicht
ein bisschen zu sehr Ideologie getrieben
man möchte das Gute machen manchmal
glaubt gar nicht angefahren man glaubt
auch gar nicht der Strom jetzt war ja da
die letzten Jahrzehnte warum soll das
künftig jetzt nicht mehr sein es gibt
viele Experten im Energiebereich die
sagen ja raus aus Atomkraft aber nicht
bevor ich andere
Kraftwerke gebaut habe was mir in
Deutschland der deutsche stromerzeugnis
zu schmutzige Seite 1990er Jahren nicht
da war natürlich Gas oder diese Russland
Situation nicht eingepreist aber aber
ist man da ein bisschen zu Ideologie
getrieben und ist das dann auch eine Art
Sicherheitsrisiko
ja vielleicht man muss es wenn man es
rückblickend betrachtet muss man
vielleicht wirklich sagen war die
Ideologie oft stärker als das gesamte
System Verständnis das kann man
vielleicht wirklich so betrachten es ist
natürlich rein von der Rationalität so
wir sind in Österreich auch wir brauchen
dabei nur nach Deutschland schauen wir
sind ausgestiegen großteils aus Versehen
Technologien aus Gras Kohlekraftwerken
wir werden auch schon das Gaskraftwerken
draußen hätten nicht wir sie
Reservekraftwerke kontrolliert aber
natürlich der Thomas steht in
Deutschland der Kohleausstieg in
Deutschland ich sage jetzt mal es wäre
vernünftig bevor man das etwas rausgeht
dass man das andere reingeht ja das wäre
schon im Grunde im grundlegend Navigator
der Vorgang den man sich ja überlegen
sollte und das ist ein bisschen so das
übergeordnete Problem die sich auch in
der Entschuldigung auch ein bisschen in
der Politik sehe man ist natürlich sehr
in Favoriten die diese Erneuerbaren zu
Buschen ja und das das wollen ja eh alle
und das ist auch nicht mehr die
Fragestellung ob wir jetzt irgendwie
noch einmal fossile Technologien gehen
aber es ist so dann man rühmt sich dann
und wir sind schon so weit so viel
prozentuell soweit mit den CO2 Missionen
nach unten und der andere soweit aber am
Ende des Tages muss das System
funktionieren und das ist das was wir
glaube ich auch aus dieser Krise jetzt
gesehen haben hätten wir vor dem 24.2 in
der Bevölkerung jemanden gefragt was
begründet unseren Wohlstand ich glaube
die wenigsten hätten gesagt eine sichere
Energie oder Stromversorgung man hätte
viele andere Aspekte gefunden aber
sicher nicht dass es unsere
Infrastruktur funktioniert dass die
Stromversorgung da ist und so weiter und
wir wurden glaube ich seit dem 24 und in
den letzten Monaten eines wirklich eines
Besseren belehrt und erkennen jetzt
eigentlich erst und es ist auch für mich
eine interessante Wahrnehmung in den
letzten Monaten oder Jahren war es
eigentlich die Energiewende und der die
Klima Krise die diesen Erneuerbaren Boom
erzeugt hat oder getrieben hat jetzt
wird es die Versorgung Sicherheit sein
also was dieser Konflikte noch keine
bewirkt hat ist die Tatsache dass der
einzelne Haushalt eigentlich
wahrscheinlich gar nicht immer nur wegen
der Klima Thematik sich eine
befahranlage montiert sondern weil der
energieautark werden will weil einfach
Angst hat dass er morgen oder übermorgen
keinen Strom mehr hat und das wird uns
sozusagen in diese Richtung treiben und
das ist vielleicht noch der positiven
Aspekt wenn man irgendwas positives ist
im Krieg sehen will dass wir vielleicht
doch jetzt erkennen in Europa nämlich
aus dem Sicherheitsdenken heraus dass
wir uns loslösen müssen von fossilen
Abhängigkeiten das wir nicht weiter 80%
unseres Gasbedarfs aus Russland kriegen
können und dass wir einfach schauen
müssen dass wir in Europa uns auf eigene
Beine stellen die Ressourcen die wir
haben bestmöglich nutzen und dann dort
und es muss so ehrlich muss man auch
sehen wir werden nicht alle premier
Energie die wir brauchen wir brauchen
derzeit rund 320 Terawattstunden Energie
in Österreich
dass wir wenn man wir reden beim Strom
ist es nur 20% davon das sind nur 70
Jahre Stunden in Strom davon und dass
wir hier einfach auch Partner finden wo
immer die dann sind Wasserstoff
importieren was alles danach an
Technologien zu entwickeln ist um
einfach in Summe mehr unabhängig zu sein
also die Krise quasi jetzt auch als
Chance zu sehen hier andere Dinge zu
hinterfragen Frau Botschafterin weil sie
vorher so
positiven Appell was die Neutralität
oder Plädoyer für die Neutralität
gesprochen haben sie haben auch schon
vorher angesprochen sie Schweiz schon
sehr diskutiert aber jetzt quasi die
jüngste Entscheidung in dieser Woche war
für viele überraschen nämlich
das Waffen in der Schweiz hergestellt
worden sind von anderen Staaten an die
Ukraine weitergegeben werden dürften ich
denke das ist gerade noch ein Prozess
der diskutiert wird was war der Grund
jedenfalls für diese Entwicklung ist das
was sie vorher gemeint haben neutral
bedeutet militärisch neutral aber eben
nicht Werte neutral
ja genau also die Schweiz ich weiß nicht
ob ich Ihre Frage richtig verstanden
habe die Schweiz verbietet weiterhin den
Export von von Schweiz in der Schweiz
produzierten Waffen durch Drittländer
oder und
der Grund dafür
ist ist einfach das kriegsmaterialgesetz
der Schweiz lässt dies im aktuellen
zuständigen aktuellen Situation nicht zu
und der Bundesrat hat das auch die
Schweizer Bundesrat hat das auch
bestätigt es läuft eine Debatte oder es
wurde eine Debatte Land sieht von den
sicherheitspolitischen Kommissionen im
Parlament zu fragen ob dieses Gesetz
reduziert werden soll aber diese Debatte
läuft und solange die nicht
abgeschlossen ist und keine Entscheidung
vorliegen und
diese Entscheidung unterstellt werden
würden in der Schweiz Demokratie ist das
die aktuelle Position des Bundes
weil wie sie gesagt haben oder
wiederholt haben oder fakt ist als
neutrale Staat ist die Schweiz
militärisch neutral
das ist nicht einfach zu kommunizieren
oder also
Neutralität oder diese Wahrnehmung der
Neutralität als
moralische Äquidistanz ist nicht korrekt
das ist eine militärische Neutralität
und das bedingt von der Schweiz von uns
aus als Staat und eben auf anderen Wegen
sie aktiv und sehr engagiert für die
Solidarität einzusetzen und das sei das
im Rahmen des Wiederaufbau sicher gehen
und die Ukraine Konferenz die letztes
Jahr in Lugano durchgeführt wurde also
eine Entwicklungshilfe in der
Flüchtlingshilfe in den humanitärenhilfe
in den humanitären Entminung
zu fragen humanitäter ich habe das
vorhin gewählt
zu fragen dass das kulturgüteschutzes wo
die Schweiz unterstützen kann also die
Schweiz als neutrale Stadt muss nicht
nur einfach sprechen wir müssen agieren
wir müssen solidarisch sein aber wir
sind militärisch neutral und das in
eine Zeit zu kommunizieren
in die Kommunikation als
Hyperkommunikation daher kommt oder also
man
Social Media etablierte Medien
Diskussionen im Land selber
Missverständnisse oder vielleicht
Unklarheiten zu fragen was ist
Neutralitätspolitik und was ist
Neutralität recht das ist für die
Schweiz im Bundesrat eine große
Herausforderung das Konzis kommunizieren
zu können und und
da sind wir daran gerade auch und die
konnten die Komplexität wird eben noch
erhöht dadurch dass wir in der Schweiz
eine wirklich intensive Debatte darüber
führen
zu kommunizieren wenn überhaupt noch
departiert wird aber das das Recht ist
das Recht wie wir es interpretieren und
der Bundesrat ist als politische
Entscheidung auch so gesetzt hat
wenn ich vielleicht noch etwas sagen
darf zu fragen Hybrid weil ich finde das
eine interessante de hatte Hybrid heißt
ja eigentlich dass beides eben
getroffen ist also die die
konventionelle Kriegsführung und all die
Alternative kriegsführungen oder und ich
glaube füreinander wie die Schweiz für
uns ist es wichtig dass wir unsere
Militärbudget so einsetzen dass eben
beide das konventionelle und das nicht
konventionelle abgedeckt ist
immerhin 41%
unserer Rüstungs unseres Rüstungs
etwas geht in Rüstung oder das ist mehr
als jede Natur statt es ist mir als die
USA als die Türkei
gleichzeitig müssen wir aber eben auch
modernisieren und und auch nicht
konventionelle Risiken und Gefahren
unsere unsere Streitkräfte und unsere
Verteidigungslinien sage ich mal darauf
adaptieren und das und das geschieht in
ein
pflegezielten Art und Weise das ist
wichtig wir brauchen das gerade weil wir
neutral sind
finden Frage an Sie Herr Gady jetzt ist
also wenn das mitbekommen die USA und
Deutschland haben also zugestimmt
Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine zu schicken
jetzt sagen Experten wie sie es gab
davor auch schon schwere Waffen die in
die Ukraine geschickt wurden es wird
alle voraussichtlich wohl auch
Kampfflugzeug gebrauchen irgendjemand
wird diesen Panzer womöglich beschützen
müssen es konnte man dann in der Nacht
auf heute auch hören dass die Amerikaner
keine Waffengattungen Zitat ausschließen
wollen
ist jetzt nach der panzerdebatte wird
vor der Kampfflugzeug Debatte und ist
das alles nicht viel zu spät
also früher oder später wird
wahrscheinlich die Ukraine auch
westliche Kampfflugzeuge bekommen ob das
jetzt unmittelbar ist kann ich mir also
nächsten Monaten relativ schwer
vorstellen
die Luftwaffe an sich in diesem Konflikt
oder die Rolle der Luftwaffe in diesen
Konflikt war bis dato relativ
limitiert auf dem Gefechtsfeld natürlich
gibt es auch eine strategische Kampagne
Russland hier mit
marschflugkörpernalistischen Raketen und
Drohnen und so weiter diene die
kritische Infrastruktur der Ukraine
zerstören wollen
Kampfflugzeuge werden da natürlich eine
Hilfe auch gegen diese Kampagne ich
glaube diese Debatte wird auf jeden Fall
geführt werden ich glaube sie wird aber
noch kontroverses sein als die Debatte
um die Panzerlieferungen und ich glaube
ein großer Fehler und der wird nicht so
sehr hier und also in Berlin gegangen
aber vielleicht in anderen Ländern
teilweise so zu tun als ob wir die
gesamte nukleare Dimension oder
Eskalation
in diesem Krieg komplett ignorieren
können das können wir nicht ja ich
schätze die
das Risiko als noch sehr gering ein aber
ein sehr geringes Risiko in einer
nuklearen Dimension ist trotzdem noch
ein hohes Risiko also wir müssen hier
auch sehr klar und konkret über
Konsequenzen etwaige Waffenlieferungen
selbstverständlich nachdenken wir können
einfach diese Dimension und die
eskalationsdynamik nicht ignorieren das
heißt nicht das Kampfflugzeuge das
unmittelbar verursachen würden aber es
ist etwas was im Hinterkopf bei jeder
Debatte natürlich auch bleiben muss
ich danke sehr herzlich für diese
abstehenworte ich es ist schade wir
haben fast ein bisschen zu wenig Zeit
für unser Panel weil ich mit ihnen ich
hoffe sie sehen das auch so könnte man
dann noch deutlich länger weiter
diskutieren ich sage es mal einfach nur
Dankeschön an sie alle auch ganz liebe
Grüße nach London an Frau Franke ich
bitte sie bleiben noch ein bisschen
sitzen bei uns und ich bitte sie sind
herzlich willkommen im Applaus für
unsere Teilnehmer
[Applaus]
abschließend bitte ich jetzt den
Generalsekretär des
Verteidigungsministeriums auf die Bühne
und um seine abschließenden Worte welche
verteidigungspolitischen Konklusion
ergeben sich jetzt auch aus all dem was
manche was wir hier auch gesagt haben
bitte genau vielen herzlichen Dank sehr
geehrte Frau Bundesministerin Herr
Generalanwalt geschätzte Vertreter aus
Politik Diplomatie und Militär meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren es wurde
bereits alles gesagt und nicht von jedem
Mann und nachdem man auch die Zeit schon
relativ fortgeschritten ist und bei
meiner oder anderen der Magen schon zu
knurren beginnt gestanden sie mir
dennoch in aller Kürze Ihnen vielleicht
den einen oder anderen Gedanken mit ins
Wochenende mit auf den Weg zu geben nach
all dem was wir hier am Vormittag gehört
haben
wenn immer wieder über
Sicherheitspolitik und
Verteidigungspolitik im letzten Jahr
seit dem 24 Februar 2022 gesprochen
haben so ist in 95% der Fällen immer
eine Referenz zur Zeitenwende zur Zäsur
da ich erinnere daran dass im Jahr 2008
wir haben schon das ein oder andere Buch
Zitat heute gehört Robert kegen ein Buch
geschrieben hat mit dem Titel The Return
of history and of Dreams indem er
beschrieben hat dass unsere Vorstellung
dass durch Fortschritts und Friede alles
Gute in diese Welt einkehren wird und
dass damit macht Konfrontationen
ausgeschlossen werden das dem vielleicht
nicht ganz so Rechnung zu tragen ist wir
sehen spätestens seit einem Jahr dass
das eine Realität ist und wenn wir den
zweiten Teil des Buchtitels hernehmen
die end of Unternehmens so müssen wir
uns die Frage stellen haben wir
aufgehört zu träumen
sind wir aufgeweckt worden aber sind wir
wirklich aufgewacht
wir haben vieles an Risiken und
Herausforderungen hier im Laufe des
heutigen vormittags gehört
wir haben große Worte große Schlagzeilen
gehört strategische Autonomie der
Europäischen Union
Abhängigkeiten zu reduzieren wir müssen
autonomer werden als Europa wir müssen
die geistige Landesverteidigung die
umfassende Landesverteidigung
entsprechend stärken
wenn wir uns aber selbstkritisch fragen
so müssen wir doch auch für unser
geistiges Auge führen wo stehen wir bei
all diesen großen Schlagwörtern wie
oftmals relativ leichter in diesem
Kontext verwenden
wo stehen wir
trübt nicht vielleicht auch der
verständlicherweise klare Fokus und
klare Blicke auf den Krieg in der
Ukraine unsere Einschätzung von dem was
ich sonst in der Welt tut vergessen wir
nicht vielleicht dabei auch andere
Krisen und Konfliktherde andere
Herausforderungen mit denen wir
konfrontiert sind und auch das auch wenn
es ein Notarzt ist sei klar
ausgesprochen wir können in der
Geopolitik viel ändern was wir nicht
ändern können ist die Geographie
wir sind dort und wir bleiben dort wo
sich auch Europa als Kontinent befindet
wir sind mit Instabilitäten in unserer
östlichen Nachbarschaft in unsere
südlichen Nachbarschaft konfrontiert wir
merken mittelfristig auf die
Konsequenzen die beispielsweise der
Klimawandel nach sich zieht und wenn wir
davon reden dass wir unsere
Abhängigkeiten reduzieren wollen dass
wir autonome werden wollen als Europa so
müssen wir auch vor unserer geistiges
Auge und die Frage stellen von wem
machen wir uns autonomer was können wir
auch noch selbst entsprechend machen und
ich sage Ihnen nur eines wenn sie als
eine Konsequenz des Klimawandels
hernehmen das vielleicht mittelfristig
sowohl die Nordwest als auch die
Nordostpassage permanent schiffbar sein
wird das damit eine Verkürzung der
Handelswege wenn Sie die Strecke Hamburg
Tokio beispielsweise hier nehmen von
bisher 21.000 km sicher auf 14.000
Kilometer um ein Drittel reduziert so
hat das entsprechende Auswirkungen und
ich glaube auch das ist ein wesentlicher
Faktor wenn wir über die Reduktion der
Abhängigkeiten reden welche Art der
projektionsfähigkeit haben wir überhaupt
als Europa oder auch als Österreich wo
sind wir wo stehen wir und wenn wir über
Sie und Handelsrouten reden denken Sie
an die großen seestraßen angefangen von
der Straße von Malaka über die Straße
von Hormus den Golf von Aden jetzt in
den letzten Tagen der Golf von Guinea
alles für uns
alles für uns relevante Märkte und
Regionen wo auch unsere sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitisches augenmerkte
liegen sollte wo sind wir und wenn wir
von da Reduktion der Abhängigkeiten
reden das ist heute am Vormittag auch
das Wort der dekarbonisierung gefallen
sollten wir auch da meiner Meinung nach
nicht den gleichen Fehler machen und
auch hier naiv sein bedeutet nicht auch
in gewisser Weise die dekarbonisierung
für die wir alle eintreten und die wir
alle intellektuell auch entsprechend
unterstützen dass wir nicht letzten
Endes eigentlich nur die Rohstoffe
ändern aber nicht die Abhängigkeiten
auch das sollten wir uns als Europa und
das Österreich für unser Auge führen
zweiter Gedanke den ich Ihnen gerne
mitgeben möchte im Jahr 2013 und die
hier im Saal die sich länger mit der
europäischen sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik beschäftigt haben
werden sich daran erinnern können haben
wir davon geredet es gab einen
Europäischen Rat der Staats-
zwei Monate vor dem Ausbruch unter
Annexion der Krim wurden große
Beschlüsse auf europäischer Ebene
geschafft dass wir uns mit Fragen der
Verteidigung und Verteidigungspolitik
intensiv auseinandersetzen müssen auch
hier gilt es selbstkritisch festzuhalten
was haben wir seitdem gemacht
wir erleben auch seit dem Jahr 2022 umso
mehr die Bedeutung und den Mehrwert
einer Verteidigung die eine umfassende
sein muss die gesamtstaatlich und ich
freue mich auch dass der Präsident des
Gemeindebundes Alfred Riedel hier unter
uns ist weil auf den Gemeinden einen
entsprechende Bedeutung hier auch
zukommt dass wir diese Verteidigung
umfassend denken müssen
ich glaube auch hier geht es noch sehr
viele Hausaufgaben die wir
innerstaatlich aber die wir auch im
europäischen Verbund zu denken haben und
wenn sie alljährlich zu dieser
Veranstaltung kommen und ich habe sie im
April letzten Jahres hier auch gesagt
wir freuen uns zwar als
Verteidigungsministerium dass wir Ihnen
das Risiko Bild des
Verteidigungsministeriums präsentieren
können wir müssen aber auch hier an den
Punkt gelangen dass wir ein gemeinsames
risikobild ein gemeinsames Verständnis
in der gesamten Republik über die
Herausforderungen und Bedrohungen haben
dritter Punkt Dritter Gedanke den ich
Ihnen mitgeben möchte betrifft den
Bereich Kommunikation
viele werden vielleicht nach dem
eingangsvideo nach den ersten
Darstellungen einen Gemütszustand
ähnliches Wetters heute hier in Wien
gehabt haben es ist trüb der Ausblick
ist leicht vernebelt die Sonne bisher
nicht wirklich gesehen ich glaube es ist
unsere Aufgabe und unsere Pflicht als
Verteidigungspolitiker dass wir hier
auch insoferne zum Diskurs beitragen
dass wir ihnen nicht geschönt sondern
real die Herausforderungen und
Bedrohungen skizzieren die wir
analysiert haben damit darüber auch
entsprechend diskutiert wird wir haben
auch vorhin in der Debatte wo es um
einzelne Länder gegangen ist und ihre
Positionierung oder ihren besonderen
Charakter der sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik oftmals gehört wir
müssen es kommunizieren was tun wir und
es stellt sich weder es stellt sich
weniger die Frage des entweder oder das
sondern es stellt sich die Frage
die sind auch wir als Österreicher in
der Lage zu kommunizieren welchen
solidar-beitrag wir beispielsweise im
Rahmen der Europäischen Union leisten
und wenn uns das entsprechend gelingt
dann ist es weniger eine Frage nach
Institutionen sondern eine Frage der
Glaubwürdigkeit ob wir diesen Beitrag
auch im internationalen Kontext hier
entsprechend einbringen und wenn Sie
alle dann später ein Exemplar unseres
Buches das risikobiles entsprechend mit
nach Hause nehmen schauen Sie sich den
Beitrag vom Herrn Brigitte dir vorhofer
an wo sie viele bunte Punkte bewusst
etwas flapsig entdecken werden setzen
Sie sich zu Hause hin und diskutieren
sie darüber ob der eine Punkt vielleicht
etwas weiter links und rechts das ist
jetzt nicht parteipolitisch gesprochen
oder oben oder unten sein sollte auch in
ihrer Empfindung weil es wichtigste und
im Wesentlichen auch eine glaubwürdige
sicherheits- und Verteidigungspolitik zu
haben ist dass es uns gelingt in der
Gesellschaft und in jedem einzelnen von
uns auch den Grad der Resilienz zu
stärken ich glaube das ist unsere
Aufgabe und das ist auch das was wir in
der Generaldirektion für
Verteidigungspolitik im
Bundesministerium für Landesverteidigung
mit dieser Publikation erreichen wollen
reden wir drüber reden sie drüber in
ihrem Bekanntenkreis in ihrem
Familienkreis denn wenn wir nicht bereit
sind für das was auf uns zukommt dann
wird es uns nur schwer fallen die
richtigen Antworten noch dafür zu finden
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren am
Ende dieses spannenden vormittags liegt
es an mir mich zu bedanken ich bedanke
mich zum einen bei der wirklich
exzellenten Moderation oder Durchführung
durch das Programm ist sondern Werner
seikal er ist kurzfristig eingesprungen
hat das perfekt gemacht und uns einen
kurzlebigen Vormittag hier bereitet
vielen herzlichen Dank dafür
ich danke den penelisten für ihre
interessanten Beiträge die Sie uns hier
gegeben haben allen Autorinnen und
Autoren die am Buch am Risiko berichter
entsprechend hier auch mitgeschrieben
haben mein besonderer Dank gilt aber
auch meinem Team in der Generaldirektion
für Verteidigungspolitik manche Namen
wurde wurden schon genannt und mich
nicht in das Fettnäpfchen zu begeben
dass ich jetzt irgendjemanden nenne und
die anderen nicht ist als alle herzlich
bedankt auch diejenigen die dazu
beigetragen haben dass heute
organisatorisch diese diese vormittags
Veranstaltung so gut über die Bühne
gegangen ist Ihnen allen viel herzlichen
Dank für ihr Kommen ich kann Ihnen jetzt
schon garantieren dass wir sie auch im
nächsten Jahr wieder zu dieser
Veranstaltung einladen werden ich danke
Dir sehr geehrte Herr Generalanwalt
lieber Erwin Hammes jeder dass du uns
wieder deine Räumlichkeiten zur
Verfügung gestellt hast ich glaube es
gibt auch in dieser Hinsicht keine
besseren Ort weil es so wie du es
eingangs erwähnt hast auch nicht nur die
politische oder militärische Dimension
mit sich bringt sondern eben auch die
wirtschaftliche Mieter an Sport holt und
wir hier auch die Message in einen
breiteren Kontext freuen können nachdem
Sie alle hungrig sind erwartet sie
draußen das eine oder andere Buffet und
um politisch inkorrekt zu enden lieber
Thomas Stallinger deine Geburtstagsparty
ist hier mit eröffnet vielen herzlichen
Dank und ein schönes Wochenende
[Applaus]